programming throwdown episode 162 interactive fiction take it away patrick i feel a little bit bad that we're doing interactive fiction in a non-interactive format. So we should release this episode as an interactive fiction. Well, it's interactive if you email us, programmingthrowdown at gmail.com. Very good. This is spoken from someone who participates in social media. All right. My opening topic is picking game difficulty settings.
programming throwdown episode 162 interactive fiction take it away patrick i feel a little bit bad that we're doing interactive fiction in a non-interactive format. So we should release this episode as an interactive fiction. Well, it's interactive if you email us, programmingthrowdown at gmail.com. Very good. This is spoken from someone who participates in social media. All right. My opening topic is picking game difficulty settings.|||programming throwdown 第 162 期互动小说，帕特里克，请开始吧。我觉得我们用非互动的方式来做互动小说有点不太好。所以我们应该把这期节目作为互动小说发布。好吧，如果你给我们发邮件，编程throwdown at gmail.com，这就是互动的了。说得真好，这话听起来就像是一个玩社交媒体的人说出来的。好的。我的开场话题是选择游戏难度设置。
Jason and I were warming up in the in the green room although it's neither green nor room but we were warming up before the podcast we were talking about video games there's uh some new video games coming out people are really stoked for them i was asking him if he was into it he's like oh yeah i was like oh man i can't get into them specifically there's a new bethesda game famously previously makers of Fallout. And I just can't get into Fallout games. I know I want to. People tell me I should. And Jason gave me the revelation of like, you got to set the difficulty setting correctly.
Jason and I were warming up in the in the green room although it's neither green nor room but we were warming up before the podcast we were talking about video games there's uh some new video games coming out people are really stoked for them i was asking him if he was into it he's like oh yeah i was like oh man i can't get into them specifically there's a new bethesda game famously previously makers of Fallout. And I just can't get into Fallout games. I know I want to. People tell me I should. And Jason gave me the revelation of like, you got to set the difficulty setting correctly.|||杰森和我在休息室热身——虽然它既不是绿色也不是房间，但我们在播客开始前确实在热身——我们当时在聊电子游戏，有些新游戏要推出了，大家对此都非常兴奋。我问他感不感兴趣，他说“哦，挺感兴趣的”。我说“噢，天哪，我对它们实在提不起兴趣”。具体来说，有一款新的贝塞斯达（Bethesda）游戏，众所周知，他们以前是《辐射》（Fallout）的制作商。而我就是玩不进去《辐射》系列。我知道我很想玩。人们也告诉我应该玩。然后杰森点醒了我，说：“你得把难度设置好。”
And then I realized, I think I have this thing where I just, you know, you start the game and it gives you your difficulty settings. And it's like, you know, story mode, easy, normal, whatever. And I read the subtext. I'm like, oh, I should go for normal. But I think I just need to realize I'm not a normal gamer. And I just need to lower the difficulty settings. I guess this was ingrained in me when games didn't have difficulty settings. You know, when you open Super Mario Bros, there's no like, what mode would you like to play on you just played on the difficulty setting well yeah because of that it became a benchmark for your talent it's like have you seen world seven no you haven't you
And then I realized, I think I have this thing where I just, you know, you start the game and it gives you your difficulty settings. And it's like, you know, story mode, easy, normal, whatever. And I read the subtext. I'm like, oh, I should go for normal. But I think I just need to realize I'm not a normal gamer. And I just need to lower the difficulty settings. I guess this was ingrained in me when games didn't have difficulty settings. You know, when you open Super Mario Bros, there's no like, what mode would you like to play on you just played on the difficulty setting well yeah because of that it became a benchmark for your talent it's like have you seen world seven no you haven't you|||然后我意识到，我好像有这样一种毛病：你知道的，当你开始游戏时，它会让你选择难度设置。就像是，你知道的，剧情模式、简单、普通，随便什么。然后我解读了其中的潜台词，心想：哦，我应该选普通难度。但我觉得我只是需要认识到我不是一个普通的玩家。我只需要把难度设置调低就行了。我想这在游戏还没有难度设置的年代就已经深深印在我的脑海里了。你知道的，当你打开《超级马里奥兄弟》时，没有那种“你想以什么模式游玩”的选项，你只能以固定的难度游玩。哦，是的，正因如此，它成了衡量你天赋的标准。就像是，你见过第七世界吗？不，你没见过。
know only because of the flute yeah that's right the flute but you're right that's the temptation is to say like it's basically uh you know the game starts by asking you, are you smart or not? You're kind of like, oh, no. No, I mean, this is the worst way of looking at it, right? It's like you come into it and say, well, yeah, I'm not. I'm a smart guy. Yeah. I mean, I should clearly play this game on hard.
know only because of the flute yeah that's right the flute but you're right that's the temptation is to say like it's basically uh you know the game starts by asking you, are you smart or not? You're kind of like, oh, no. No, I mean, this is the worst way of looking at it, right? It's like you come into it and say, well, yeah, I'm not. I'm a smart guy. Yeah. I mean, I should clearly play this game on hard.|||你知道的，只有靠笛子。对，没错，是笛子。但你说得对，诱惑就在于你会觉得，这基本上就是……你知道的，游戏一开始就问你：你聪明吗？你就会想：哦，不。不，我的意思是，这是最糟糕的看待方式，对吧？就像你接触游戏时会说：好吧，我当然是。我是个聪明人。对。我的意思是，我显然应该用困难模式来玩这个游戏。
But no, that's not the right way of thinking about it. So on this topic, I learned about a new world briefly that I've never played. And so I've never been an esports gamer other than the three times I tried logging on to some multiplayer game and heard people significantly younger than me coming over the audio channels
But no, that's not the right way of thinking about it. So on this topic, I learned about a new world briefly that I've never played. And so I've never been an esports gamer other than the three times I tried logging on to some multiplayer game and heard people significantly younger than me coming over the audio channels|||但不对，这并不是正确的思考方式。所以关于这个话题，我简要了解了一个我从未玩过的新世界。因此我从来不是一个电竞玩家，除了那三次我尝试登录某些多人游戏，听到比我年轻得多的人通过语音频道|||
complaining about how bad I was and then getting booted within minutes of joining a server because I didn't know what to do. And I just persevered. Which game was this? I don't want fess up um so but i did read an article briefly which was fascinating it definitely wasn't a real life game because that would okay anyways diablo 4 there was live streamers in a race to sort of like max their character levels be the first to like complete the game and i guess the hardest setting in diablo 4 i'm not super familiar uh is you have permadeath so
complaining about how bad I was and then getting booted within minutes of joining a server because I didn't know what to do. And I just persevered. Which game was this? I don't want fess up um so but i did read an article briefly which was fascinating it definitely wasn't a real life game because that would okay anyways diablo 4 there was live streamers in a race to sort of like max their character levels be the first to like complete the game and i guess the hardest setting in diablo 4 i'm not super familiar uh is you have permadeath so|||抱怨我有多菜，然后加入服务器几分钟内就被踢了，因为我不知道该做什么。而我只是坚持了下来。这是什么游戏？我不想坦白，嗯……不过我确实粗略读了一篇文章，非常引人入胜。绝对不是现实生活中的游戏，因为那会……好吧，总之是《暗黑破坏神 4》（Diablo 4），当时有主播在竞速，看谁能先把角色等级练满，第一个通关游戏。我猜《暗黑破坏神 4》里最难的设置——我不是很熟悉——是永久死亡机制，所以
if your character dies that's like that's it like it wipes it from the game oh wow and so if you cannot die even once while leveling up your character getting to the hardest thing completing the game going through these dungeons whatever right you imagine you have an internet hiccup or something it's devastating so this is what happened so the person i guess you're teeing it up very nicely uh so something about and i don't this is where it sort of starts to fall if i didn't care enough to read deeply so i guess like the first 100 people to like beat it in this certain mode we're going to be like carved into a statue in the headquarters of blizzard i think makes diablo yeah that's right and so they're going to like engra it in this certain mode, we're going to be like carved into a statue in the headquarters of Blizzard, I think makes Diablo 4.
if your character dies that's like that's it like it wipes it from the game oh wow and so if you cannot die even once while leveling up your character getting to the hardest thing completing the game going through these dungeons whatever right you imagine you have an internet hiccup or something it's devastating so this is what happened so the person i guess you're teeing it up very nicely uh so something about and i don't this is where it sort of starts to fall if i didn't care enough to read deeply so i guess like the first 100 people to like beat it in this certain mode we're going to be like carved into a statue in the headquarters of blizzard i think makes diablo yeah that's right and so they're going to like engra it in this certain mode, we're going to be like carved into a statue in the headquarters of Blizzard, I think makes Diablo 4.|||如果你的角色死了，那就彻底完了，游戏会直接把角色抹掉。哦，哇。所以如果在升级角色、挑战最难的内容、通关游戏、通过这些地下城等过程中，你连一次都不能死，对吧？想象一下，如果你的网络卡顿了一下什么的，那简直是毁灭性的。事情就是这样的：这个人，我想你铺垫得很好，嗯……所以关于……我没有足够关心去深入阅读，所以这部分我有点记不清了。我猜前 100 名在这个特定模式下通关的人，会被雕刻成雕像，放在暴雪总部的办公室里，暴雪开发了《暗黑》系列。对，没错。所以他们会把名字……在特定模式下通关的人，会被雕刻成雕像，放在暴雪总部的办公室里，暴雪开发了《暗黑破坏神 4》。
Yeah, that's right. And so they were going to like engrave their names on a statue or whatever. And one of the things I didn't realize is exactly this. So the way the sort of like top runner, the front runner ended up dying is he had a brief internet glitch. He or she actually don't know. They had a brief internet glitch. And so in order to prevent people disconnecting when they
Yeah, that's right. And so they were going to like engrave their names on a statue or whatever. And one of the things I didn't realize is exactly this. So the way the sort of like top runner, the front runner ended up dying is he had a brief internet glitch. He or she actually don't know. They had a brief internet glitch. And so in order to prevent people disconnecting when they|||是的，没错。所以他们会把名字刻在雕像上之类的。我没有意识到的一点正是这个。所以那个领先的玩家、领跑者最终死掉的方式是，他的网络短暂故障了。他或她，其实我不知道。他们的网络短暂故障了。所以为了防止玩家在断开连接时……
got into a fight above their level they instituted exactly what jason alluded to if you have an internet hiccup not that your your character they will kill your character not that your character could die in the game but they will actually just kill it because they think you're trying to cheat basically like intentionally yes oh no so it's like anti-cheat measure and so this is what happened the guy had an internet, the person had an internet hiccup and their, you know, front-running character, they had spent many hours doing, anyways, bit the dust.
got into a fight above their level they instituted exactly what jason alluded to if you have an internet hiccup not that your your character they will kill your character not that your character could die in the game but they will actually just kill it because they think you're trying to cheat basically like intentionally yes oh no so it's like anti-cheat measure and so this is what happened the guy had an internet, the person had an internet hiccup and their, you know, front-running character, they had spent many hours doing, anyways, bit the dust.|||陷入超出自身等级的战斗中，他们制定了正如杰森所暗示的那样：如果你网络卡顿了——并不是说你的角色会在游戏中自然死亡，他们会直接杀死你的角色——不是说你的角色可能在游戏中阵亡，而是他们真的会直接干掉它，因为他们认为你是在故意作弊，基本上就是这样，哦不！所以这就像是一个反作弊措施。事情就是这样发生的，那个家伙的网络，那个人遇到了网络卡顿，他们那个花了无数个小时培养的领先角色，就这样完蛋了。
Oh, man, unbelievable. You know, hour, hundreds of hours, dozens of hours. Yeah, it was brutal. I mean, why is that any better than just letting your character stand there and get hit by the enemies? I mean, it seems like at least that way you have a chance of coming back.
Oh, man, unbelievable. You know, hour, hundreds of hours, dozens of hours. Yeah, it was brutal. I mean, why is that any better than just letting your character stand there and get hit by the enemies? I mean, it seems like at least that way you have a chance of coming back.|||天哪，难以置信。你知道的，几百个小时，几十个小时。是的，太残酷了。我的意思是，这怎么能比让你的角色站在那里挨打更好呢？我的意思是，至少那样的话你还有机会回来。
To reconnect? Yeah, I'm not sure. I mean, it's also a new game. Something about the game, maybe disconnecting. Like there's some technical thing. But that is what... Can you imagine you go into work, and the first thing you see is a giant statue with 10 usernames from the internet?
To reconnect? Yeah, I'm not sure. It's also a new game. Something about the game, maybe disconnecting. Like there's some technical thing. But that is what... Can you imagine you go into work, and the first thing you see is a giant statue with 10 usernames from the internet?|||重新连接？是的，我不确定。这也是一款新游戏。关于这款游戏，也许是断开连接的机制。有什么技术上的原因吧。但这就是……你能想象你去上班，第一眼看到的是一座巨大的雕像，上面刻着 10 个来自互联网的用户名吗？
But yeah, that's... Oh's oh yeah so the difficulty so you know i i went into it when i was when i was younger you know thinking yeah the difficulty is really like an iq test type thing and uh i remember i played sim earth on the super nintendo in like the year like 1989 or something whenever it came out 91 or something and i remember um they said oh if you can beat this the modern era level in sim earth on hard then you know you're good enough to be like actually president like literally president and uh you know i was really, really gullible child. So I actually believed it. And I spent countless hours, I finally beat it on hard. And I actually felt like, okay, now I'm ready. You know, yeah, I'm not born in this country. I'm born in Canada,
But yeah, that's... Oh's oh yeah so the difficulty so you know i i went into it when i was when i was younger you know thinking yeah the difficulty is really like an iq test type thing and uh i remember i played sim earth on the super nintendo in like the year like 1989 or something whenever it came out 91 or something and i remember um they said oh if you can beat this the modern era level in sim earth on hard then you know you're good enough to be like actually president like literally president and uh you know i was really, really gullible child. So I actually believed it. And I spent countless hours, I finally beat it on hard. And I actually felt like, okay, now I'm ready. You know, yeah, I'm not born in this country. I'm born in Canada,|||但是，是的，那是……哦，对，所以难度……你知道的，我年轻的时候玩游戏时，会觉得“是的，难度真的就像智商测试一样”，呃，我记得我在超级任天堂（Super Nintendo）上玩过《模拟地球》（SimEarth），大约是在 1989 年左右，或者它发售的时候，91 年什么的。我记得……他们说：哦，如果你能在困难难度下通关《模拟地球》里的现代纪元关卡，那你就有资格当总统了，字面意思上的总统。呃，你知道的，我是一个非常非常容易轻信别人的孩子。所以我真的相信了。我花了无数的时间，终于在困难难度下通关了。我甚至觉得：好吧，现在我准备好了。你知道的，虽然我不是在这个国家出生的，我出生在加拿大，
but that's okay. I have my SIPR high score. And I'm just gonna walk into the White House. So if Jason ever gets a trip to the White House, I guess that's the question he's going to ask. So how long did it take you to be? Oh, yeah. But now, you know, and this could be just a natural cycle. And so maybe this advice doesn't apply to everybody. But I got to the point now where I say, you know, how can I maximize my fun? And if, you know, in a lot of these Bethesda games, what I find fun is exploring all the different ways that you can do things like the ways you can manipulate the physics. And yeah, I have a character that has a big sword, but also a little sword and a shield and fireballs and everything and a bow
but that's okay. I have my SIPR high score. And I'm just gonna walk into the White House. So if Jason ever gets a trip to the White House, I guess that's the question he's going to ask. So how long did it take you to be? Oh, yeah. But now, you know, and this could be just a natural cycle. And so maybe this advice doesn't apply to everybody. But I got to the point now where I say, you know, how can I maximize my fun? And if, you know, in a lot of these Bethesda games, what I find fun is exploring all the different ways that you can do things like the ways you can manipulate the physics. And yeah, I have a character that has a big sword, but also a little sword and a shield and fireballs and everything and a bow|||但没关系。我有我的 SIPR 高分纪录。我可以直接走进白宫了。所以如果杰森有机会去白宫，我想这就是他会问的问题。所以你花了多长时间才通关？哦，是的。但现在，你知道的，这可能只是一个自然的循环。所以也许这个建议并不适用于所有人。但我现在已经到了这样一个阶段，我会说：你知道的，我如何才能让我的快乐最大化？如果，你知道的，在许多这样的贝塞斯达游戏中，我发现有趣的是探索你可以做事情的各种不同方法，比如你可以操纵物理定律的方式。是的，我有一个拿着大剑的角色，但也有一把小剑、一面盾牌、火球以及其他所有东西，还有一张弓
and arrow. And so because of that, the way these Bethesda games work is if the less specialized you are, the harder the game is because the monsters are all specialized. And as you go through the game, you're just not leveling any one thing up high enough to take on these monsters and so you know you have to compensate for that by not playing on really hard difficulty and if and and on the converse it's also true like you could play on really hard difficulty and if you focus on one thing then you can have a much easier time but now for me the difficulty has been more like what is going to maximize the fun like i played this game called terra nil which was a puzzle game i started playing it on normal and i realized like i got through like 20 of the content in 15 minutes or something oh i realized that okay yeah i need
and arrow. And so because of that, the way these Bethesda games work is if the less specialized you are, the harder the game is because the monsters are all specialized. And as you go through the game, you're just not leveling any one thing up high enough to take on these monsters and so you know you have to compensate for that by not playing on really hard difficulty and if and and on the converse it's also true like you could play on really hard difficulty and if you focus on one thing then you can have a much easier time but now for me the difficulty has been more like what is going to maximize the fun like i played this game called terra nil which was a puzzle game i started playing it on normal and i realized like i got through like 20% of the content in 15 minutes or something oh i realized that okay yeah i need|||和箭。正因如此，这些贝塞斯达游戏的运作方式是：你的专精程度越低，游戏就越难，因为怪物都是专精的。随着你在游戏中前进，你根本没有把任何一项专精升级到足够高来对付这些怪物，所以你知道你必须通过不在非常困难的难度下玩来弥补这一点。反之亦然，比如你可以在非常困难的难度下玩，如果你专注于一件事，那么你会轻松得多。但现在对我来说，难度更多的是“什么能让快乐最大化”。就像我玩了一款名为《伊始之地》（Terra Nil）的游戏，那是一个益智游戏，我一开始用普通难度玩，然后我意识到我大概在 15 分钟内就通关了 20% 的内容。哦，我意识到，好吧，是的，我需要
to play this on a harder difficulty otherwise i'm not gonna get my money's worth but then for all the bethesda games i tried on hard and just got wrecked because i wasn't planning ahead with my character so so yeah that's my best advice is really just tune the difficulty the games where you have to pick the difficulty at the beginning that's actually i think becoming kind of a anti-pattern in game design. It kind of forces your hand a little bit too early. Yeah, I could believe that. I think there's also the equivalent, I guess, would be where do you find yourself if you play Minecraft? I guess it's ubiquitous enough. Like whether you allow yourself to go into creative to kind of give yourself a little bit of a head start so you can play survival mode enjoyably or are you like no staunchly like i can only use diamond materials
to play this on a harder difficulty otherwise i'm not gonna get my money's worth but then for all the bethesda games i tried on hard and just got wrecked because i wasn't planning ahead with my character so so yeah that's my best advice is really just tune the difficulty the games where you have to pick the difficulty at the beginning that's actually i think becoming kind of a anti-pattern in game design. It kind of forces your hand a little bit too early. Yeah, I could believe that. I think there's also the equivalent, I guess, would be where do you find yourself if you play Minecraft? I guess it's ubiquitous enough. Like whether you allow yourself to go into creative to kind of give yourself a little bit of a head start so you can play survival mode enjoyably or are you like no staunchly like i can only use diamond materials|||用更高的难度来玩这个，否则就对不起我的票价了。但对于所有的贝塞斯达游戏，我尝试过困难难度，结果却被虐得很惨，因为我没有提前为我的角色做规划。所以，是的，我最好的建议真的是根据情况调整难度。那些必须在一开始就选择难度的游戏，我认为这实际上正在成为游戏设计中的一种反模式（anti-pattern）。它有点太早地强迫你做出选择了。是的，我能相信这一点。我想还有与之对应的情况，那就是如果你玩《我的世界》（Minecraft），你会怎么做？我想它已经足够无处不在了。比如，你是允许自己进入创造模式来给自己一点优势，从而愉快地玩生存模式呢？还是说你坚决认为我只能使用钻石材料？
that i actually mined from the bottom of the earth you know like they're like who who's to say one is right and one is wrong like yep yep i think it's a balance between like uh enjoying yourself in the moment versus having the satisfaction you know at the end and so you're kind of trading off one for the other well cool i'm gonna move into my first uh news article and that is uh i oh this is this is i gotta caveat this this is a supposedly internal Supposedly internal memo at Google to Googlers about them having no AI moat, but neither does open AI. We've kind of referenced this before, but I'm putting this link in here and it's just one particular analysis of this. But basically the upshot being here that, you know, a lot of people believe we're at sort of a pivot point for AI and these models. And there's sort of this race to get them all implemented and be first mover.
that i actually mined from the bottom of the earth you know like they're like who who's to say one is right and one is wrong like yep yep i think it's a balance between like uh enjoying yourself in the moment versus having the satisfaction you know at the end and so you know you're kind of trading off one for the other well cool i'm gonna move into my first uh news article and that is uh i oh this is this is i gotta caveat this this is a supposedly internal Supposedly internal memo at Google to Googlers about them having no AI moat, but neither does open AI. We've kind of referenced this before, but I'm putting this link in here and it's just one particular analysis of this. But basically the upshot being here that, you know, a lot of people believe we're at sort of a pivot point for AI and these models. And there's sort of this race to get them all implemented and be first mover.|||那些我真正从地球底部挖掘出来的材料？你知道的，这就好比……谁又能说哪种是对的，哪种是错的呢？是的，是的。我认为这是一种平衡，介于在当下享受乐趣与在最后获得满足感之间，所以你是在用其中一个来换取另一个。好吧，酷，我要进入我的第一篇新闻文章了，那是……哦，我得先加个前提说明，这是一份据称是谷歌内部发给谷歌员工的备忘录，内容是关于他们没有人工智能护城河，但 OpenAI 也没有。我们之前提到过类似的内容，但我把这个链接放在这里，这只是对此的一个特定分析。但基本上其核心结论是，你知道的，许多人认为我们正处于人工智能和这些模型的某种转折点上。并且存在着这样一种竞赛，要将它们全部实现并成为先行者。
Because in many cases, historically with technology, the sort of like first to market, you know, gets a seat at the market share table. And that's really hard to overcome. And they sort of call this, you know, a moat. So if you think about people making cell phones today, those are moats because the volume at which they do. So we hear about new laptop companies or cell phone companies every so often attempt to enter the market, but they sell so many less units that all the tooling costs. So if you buy an Apple product or a Google product, the unboxing experience, just the cost to make that box that way, you need to buy 100,000 units experience, just the cost to like make that box
Because in many cases, historically with technology, the sort of like first to market, you know, gets a seat at the market share table. And that's really hard to overcome. And they sort of call this, you5 can think about people making cell phones today, those are moats because the volume at which they do. So we hear about new laptop companies or cell phone companies every so often attempt to enter the market, but they sell so many less units that all the tooling costs. So if you buy an Apple product or a Google product, the unboxing experience, just the cost to make that box that way, you need to buy 100,000 units experience, just the cost to like make that box|||因为在许多情况下，从历史上的技术来看，率先进入市场的人，你知道的，能在市场份额的餐桌上占有一席之地。而这真的很难被超越。他们把这称为……你可以想想今天制造手机的人，这些就是护城河，因为他们的出货量巨大。所以我们每隔一段时间就会听到新的笔记本电脑公司或手机公司试图进入市场，但他们的销量要少得多，以至于所有的模具和工具成本……所以如果你买一个苹果产品或谷歌产品，开箱体验，光是把那个盒子做成那个样子的成本，你就需要购买 10 万个单元开箱体验，光是制作那个盒子的成本
that way, you need to buy, you know, 100,000 units, which if you're a startup, that's really hard to sell that much hardware. And so there, it's not clear yet for AI, if people getting there first are going to have a moat, and what kind of data may be necessary, and who has that data. And if you sort of have somebody coming and using your service and essentially giving you feedback and ratings against how you're doing, is that first mover advantage going to prove to be a moat? And so this internal article, one, just an interesting analysis, I think, of how the different moving pieces of AI. So there's the data, there's the feedback, there's the training and how you do the training.
that way, you need to buy, you know, 100,000 units, which if you're a startup, that's really hard to sell that much hardware. And so there, it's not clear yet for AI, if people getting there first are going to have a moat, and what kind of data may be necessary, and who has that data. And if you sort of have somebody coming and using your service and essentially giving you feedback and ratings against how you're doing, is that first mover advantage going to prove to be a moat? And so this internal article, one, just an interesting analysis, I think, of how the different moving pieces of AI. So there's the data, there's the feedback, there's the training and how you do the training.|||那样的话，你需要购买，你知道的，10 万个单元，如果你是一家初创公司，要卖出那么多硬件是非常难的。所以对于人工智能来说，目前还不清楚率先进入的人是否会拥有护城河，什么样的数据可能是必要的，以及谁拥有这些数据。如果你有某个人来使用你的服务，并基本上就你做得怎么样向你提供反馈和评分，这种先发优势会被证明是一条护城河吗？因此这篇内部文章，一方面，我认为是对人工智能各个活动部件如何运作的一个有趣的分析。所以这里有数据，有反馈，有训练以及你如何进行训练。
But there's also having others do optimization on your models for you and in your frameworks and making them run on lower capacity devices. So if we look at and we've talked about a few of those on the show, but like OpenAI, ChatGPT, but then others are approaching that level with significantly cheaper hardware. So they kind of had to figure it out, but now others can replicate it on a single computer with much more limited data sets. And so this was sort of an internal memo, but I'm just using it as that sort of topic that is interesting to me from an economic standpoint.
But there's also having others do optimization on your models for you and in your frameworks and making them run on lower capacity devices. So if we look at and we've talked about a few of those on the show, but like OpenAI, ChatGPT, but then others are approaching that level with significantly cheaper hardware. So they kind of had to figure it out, but now others can replicate it on a single computer with much more limited data sets. And so this was sort of internal memo, but I'm just using it as that sort of topic that is interesting to me from an economic standpoint.|||但还有让其他人为你优化模型、在你的框架中进行优化，并让它们在低配置设备上运行。如果我们看看——我们已经在节目中讨论过其中的一些——比如 OpenAI、ChatGPT，但随后其他人正以明显更便宜的硬件接近这一水平。所以他们不得不自己摸索出来，但现在其他人可以在单台计算机上用更有限的数据集复制它。所以这有点像是一份内部备忘录，但我只是把它作为一个从经济学角度来看对我有吸引力的话题来探讨。
I don't know if this will be transformative in the way people are, or whether this is like a sort of false start local maxima whatever kind of thing I don't know yet but no one knows and it's kind of interesting to sit there and watch as big companies try to figure it out someone was noticing that as an example bing's deployed some open ai power chatbots but then over time they've sort of gotten less useful as people have found like jailbreak escapes for like protections that were put in so that they
I don't know if this will be transformative in the way people are, or whether this is like a sort of false start local maxima whatever kind of thing I don't know yet but no one knows and it's kind of interesting to sit there and watch as big companies try to figure it out someone was noticing that as an example bing's deployed some open ai power chatbots but then over time they've sort of gotten less useful as people have found like jailbreak escapes for like protections that were put in so that they|||我不知道这是否会以人们预想的方式带来变革，或者这是否只是某种虚假起步的局部最优解之类的事情，我目前还不知道，但没有人知道，坐在那里看着大公司试图弄清楚这一切，这还挺有意思的。有人注意到，作为一个例子，必应（Bing）部署了一些由 OpenAI 驱动的聊天机器人，但随后随着时间的推移，它们变得没那么有用，因为人们找到了诸如越狱逃逸的方法来绕过内置的保护措施，以便它们
wouldn't be racist or wouldn't be discriminatory or wouldn't be, you know, doing things they wouldn't want to and people are finding like ways around it. So they keep limiting and limiting and limiting. There, it's this sort of interesting exploration of the spaces, everyone attempts to figure out what matters, what doesn't matter, what economic incentives are there or aren't there? How do we deploy our resources against it? So it's sort of fascinating in an internal look, potentially, hopefully, if that leak is true.
wouldn't be racist or wouldn't be discriminatory or wouldn't be, you know, doing things they wouldn't want to and people are finding like ways around it. So they keep limiting and limiting and limiting. There, it's this sort of interesting exploration of the spaces, everyone attempts to figure out what matters, what doesn't matter, what economic incentives are there or aren't there? How do we deploy our resources against it? So it's sort of fascinating in an internal look, potentially, hopefully, if that leak is true.|||不会表现出种族主义、不会有歧视、或者不会做……你知道的，那些他们不希望它们做的事情，而人们正在寻找绕过这些限制的方法。所以他们不断地进行限制、限制、再限制。在这里，这是对这些空间的一种有趣的探索，每个人都试图弄清楚什么重要，什么不重要，存在或不存在什么样的经济激励？我们如何针对它部署我们的资源？所以从内部视角来看，这相当迷人，如果那个泄密事件属好的话。
But an internal look at how Google is thinking about that problem and orienting itself. Yeah, that makes sense. I read that. I'm not sure if I believe it or not. I do think that, you know, getting customer feedback, you know, turning that into more signal for the model and all of that, you know, you can build a moat there. But yeah, I also really curious. I think a lot of people sense just an enormous amount of uncertainty. I know I personally have been doing less Googling. For example, I recently decided the whole team is going to go to a baseball game. So we're all going to meet in the same city
But an internal look at how Google is thinking about that problem and orienting itself. Yeah, that makes sense. I read that. I'm not sure if I believe it or not. I do think that, you know, getting customer feedback, you know, turning that into more signal for the model and all of that, you know, you can build a moat there. But yeah, I also really curious. I think a lot of people sense just an enormous amount of uncertainty. I know I personally have been doing less Googling. For example, I recently decided the whole team is going to go to a baseball game. So we're all going to meet in the same city|||但这让我们得以一窥谷歌是如何思考这个问题并定位自身的。是的，这说得通。我读过那个。我不知道自己是否相信它。我确实认为，你知道的，收集客户反馈，将其转化为模型的更多信号以及所有这些，你知道的，你可以在那里建立一条护城河。但是，是的，我也很好奇。我认为许多人都能感受到巨大的不确定性。我知道我个人用谷歌搜索的次数变少了。例如，我最近决定整个团队去观看一场棒球比赛。所以我们都会在同一个城市聚首
because we're all spread out all over the country. We're all going to gather in the same city and go to a baseball game. And so I wanted to see if we could get a box office and what that costs per person and all that. So I actually went into Bard and I said, how much does a box office cost for the Pittsburgh Pirates? And it told me the answer. And this is the kind of thing where even if it hallucinates, if it hallucinates too high, then I will not do the box office. It's not a big deal. I'll just get the group tickets. It doesn't really ruin my life, right? If it hallucinates too high then i will not do the box office it's not a big deal i'll just get the group tickets it doesn't really like ruin my life right if it hallucinates too low then i'll call the person at the box office and they'll tell me the right answer same thing so it's not like it's
because we're all spread out all over the country. We're all going to gather in the same city and go to a baseball game. And so I wanted to see if we could get a box office and what that costs per person and all that. So I actually went into Bard and I said, how much does a box office cost for the Pittsburgh Pirates? And it told me the answer. And this is the kind of thing where even if it hallucinates, if it hallucinates too high, then I will not do the box office. It's not a big deal. I'll just get the group tickets. It doesn't really ruin my life, right? If it hallucinates too high then i will not do the box office it's not a big deal i'll just get the group tickets it doesn't really like ruin my life right if it hallucinates too low then i'll call the person at the box office and they'll tell me the right answer same thing so it's not like it's|||因为我们散布在全国各地。我们都要聚集在同一个城市去观看棒球比赛。所以我想看看我们是否能订到一个包厢，每个人要花多少钱之类的。所以我实际上打开了 Bard 并问道：匹兹堡海盗队的包厢要多少钱？它告诉我了答案。这就是那种情况：即使它产生幻觉，如果它估算的幻觉价格太高，那我就不订包厢了。这也没什么大不了的。我大不了买团体票就行了。这其实不会毁了我的生活，对吧？如果它估算的幻觉价格太高，那我就不订包厢了，这也没什么大不了的，我大不了买团体票就行了，这其实不会像毁了我的生活那样，对吧？如果它估算的幻觉价格太低，那我就打电话给售票处的人，他们会告诉我正确的答案，也是一样的道理。所以这并不是说
going to ruin my life if it hallucinates but uh you're right but it like saved me from having to click on a link and then you know all of that like find the right link in the page. And so that's just one example. I've definitely been doing a lot less Googling, I noticed. That's interesting. So for those like thought experiment questions, like how much does it cost to rent a private jet? Like I know it's expensive, but like how expensive is it? $10,000? $100,000? Like how is it billed? You're right. I wonder that if it has enough, ingested enough, it may be hard to Google because most of the time that you're going to get sponsored links. And I mean, I've tried before because we were having that idle conversation, which is like, how much does it cost to, you know, go to the ski town in a private jet?
going to ruin my life if it hallucinates but uh you're right but it like saved me from having to click on a link and then you know all of that like find the right link in the page. And so that's just one example. I've definitely been doing a lot less Googling, I noticed. That's interesting. So for those like thought experiment questions, like how much does it cost to rent a private jet? Like I know it's expensive, but like how expensive is it? $10,000? $100,000? Like how is it billed? You're right. I wonder that if it has enough, ingested enough, it may be hard to Google because most of the time that you're going to get sponsored links. And I mean, I've tried before because we were having that idle conversation, which is like, how much does it cost to, you know, go to the ski town in a private jet?|||它产生幻觉就会毁了我的生活，但是……嗯，你说的对，但它确实让我省去了点击链接然后……你知道的，在页面中寻找正确链接的麻烦。这只是一个例子。我注意到自己确实减少了很多谷歌搜索。这很有趣。所以对于那些类似思想实验的问题，比如租一架私人飞机要多少钱？我知道它很贵，但究竟有多贵？1 万美元？10 万美元？它是如何计费的？你说的对。我在想，如果它拥有足够的数据、消化了足够的信息，用谷歌可能很难查到，因为大多数时候你搜出来的都是赞助链接。我的意思是，我以前尝试过，因为我们当时在闲聊，就像是：坐私人飞机去滑雪小镇要花多少钱？
And it's like, get a quote. I'm like, I don't want a quote. I'm not serious. I know I'm not going to pay for it, but I do want to know how much it is. Like, I'm curious. Well, Bart nailed it. So I ended up going the group ticket route. And but you know, the same page that sells the group ticket sells the box offices, of course, they kind of watch you, they're trying to steer you into the box office. And it is basically right on, like whatever Bart said was the right answer. I think it was cool, basically around like 200 bucks a person with
And it's like, get a quote. I'm like, I don't want a quote. I'm not serious. I know I'm not going to pay for it, but I do want to know how much it is. Like, I're curious. Well, Bart nailed it. So I ended up going the group ticket route. And but you know, the same page that sells the group ticket sells the box offices, of course, they kind of watch you, they're trying to steer you into the box office. And it is basically right on, like whatever Bart said was the right answer. I think it was cool, basically around like 200 bucks a person with|||结果弹出来的是“获取报价”。我就想：我不要报价。我不是认真的。我知道我不会付钱，但我确实想知道它要多少钱。比如，我只是好奇。好吧，Bard 答对了。所以我最后选择了买团体票。但你知道的，卖团体票的同一个页面也卖包厢，当然，他们会盯着你，试图引导你买包厢。结果基本上完全正确，Bard 说多少就是正确答案。我觉得这挺酷的，一个人大概 200 美元左右，
some minimum number of people i assume but yeah yeah you actually buy the whole box but there's different sizes of boxes right but they all come out to about that and and so yeah i mean i think bard will cannibalize the the whole uh you know not 100 of course maybe not even 50%, but even if it's 10%, the other thing is I feel like a lot of the people who are moving over to Bard now are the people who will click on the expensive ads. So that's another problem. So yeah, I do think they have a right to be scared, but I do think also that there is a moat if it's done correctly. One of the things that I was really interested in kind of adjacent to that is whether this is going to be a centralizing or decentralizing force. You know, I feel like recommender systems, which is what, you know, I mostly worked on was a centralizing force. Like
some minimum number of people i assume but yeah yeah you actually buy the whole box but there's different sizes of boxes right but they all come out to about that and and so yeah i mean i think bard will cannibalize the the whole uh you know not 100% of course maybe not even 50%, but even if it's 10%, the other thing is I feel like a lot of the people who are moving over to Bard now are the people who will click on the expensive ads. So that's another problem. So yeah, I do think they have a right to be scared, but I do think also that there is a moat if it's done correctly. One of the things that I was really interested in kind of adjacent to that is whether this is going to be a centralizing or decentralizing force. You know, I feel like recommender systems, which is what, you know, I mostly worked on was a centralizing force. Like|||假设需要一定数量的最低人数，但对，对，你实际上是买下整个包厢，但包厢有不同的尺寸，对吧？不过它们的平均价格都差不多是那个数。所以，是的，我的意思是，我认为 Bard 会蚕食整个……你知道的，当然不可能是 100%，甚至可能不到 50%，但哪怕是 10%，另一件事是，我觉得现在转向 Bard 的很多人，正是那些会点击昂贵广告的人。所以这是另一个问题。所以，是的，我确实认为他们有理由感到害怕，但我也认为如果做得对的话，确实存在护城河。我真正感兴趣的与此相关的一件事是，这将会是一种集中化的力量还是去中心化的力量。你知道的，我觉得推荐系统——这是我主要从事的工作——是一种集中化的力量。就像
you have more personalization, you know more about people and what they want, and you don't tell anyone that information. You just keep it in your own company. And so you could do a better and better and better job finding content for them. Every advertising studio in every city could be using the same ChatGPT, but it's so cheap that it's kind of like it becomes almost like a utility. Where ChatGPT makes a tiny bit of money, but the people making most of the money are just these, you know, advertising boutiques spread out across the world. And so it's kind of a decentralized value. One day we'll look back and then we'll know the answer. And we'll either have been early in questions or very wrong. Well, yeah, it can't be any worse than our Bitcoin episode.
you have more personalization, you know more about people and what they want, and you don't tell anyone that information. You just keep it in your own company. And so you could do a better and better and better job finding content for them. Every advertising studio in every city could be using the same ChatGPT, but it's so cheap that it's kind of like it becomes almost like a utility. Where ChatGPT makes a tiny bit of money, but the people making most of the money are just these, you know, advertising boutiques spread out across the world. And so it's kind of a decentralized value. One day we'll look back and then we'll know the answer. And we'll either have been early in questions or very wrong. Well, yeah, it can't be any worse than our Bitcoin episode.|||你拥有更多的个性化，你对人们及其需求了解得更多，而你不会把这些信息告诉任何人。你只是把它留在你自己的公司里。因此，你可以越来越好地为他们寻找内容。每个城市的每个广告工作室都可以使用相同的 ChatGPT，但它是如此便宜，以至于它几乎变成了一种公用事业。ChatGPT 赚取微薄的利润，而真正赚大钱的人只是这些分布在世界各地的、你知道的广告精品店。所以这是一种去中心化的价值。总有一天我们会回过头来看，然后我们就会知道答案。我们要么在问题上占据了先机，要么大错特错。好吧，是的，它不会比我们的比特币那一期更糟了。
Nope, nope, nope, nope, nope. Next topic. All right, my next news is stable diffusion QR codes. This blew my mind. I really don't quite understand how it works. I thought I knew how it worked and then I read it and I realized I don't know how it worked. But what someone did is they made it so that you can have a QR code that is also like really artistically beautiful. Like it's this like scene of a person standing over a mountain and and the actual bits
Nope, nope, nope, nope, nope. Next topic. All right, my next news is stable diffusion QR codes. This blew my mind. I really don't quite understand how it works. I thought I knew how it worked and then I read it and I realized I don't know how it worked. But what someone did is they made it so that you can have a QR code that is also like really artistically beautiful. Like it's this like scene of a person standing over a mountain and and the actual bits|||不，不，不，不，不。下一个话题。好的，我的下一个新闻是 Stable Diffusion 二维码。这让我大开眼界。我真的不太明白它是怎么运作的。我以为我知道它是怎么运作的，然后我读了相关文章，才意识到我根本不知道它是怎么运作的。但有人做到了这一点：他们制作了一个二维码，它同时又具有极高的艺术美感。就像是一个人站在山顶上的场景，而实际的比特位——
of the qr code are almost unrecognizable because they've been surrounded by all this other content and it just seems to flow seamlessly um so yeah check out these qr codes they're pretty cool uh you know check out on the show notes get grab a link and take a look at them. It uses something called a control net, which I haven't done research on. But my guess is you fix the actual pixels that need to be black and white. You fix those or at least some percent of them. And then you allow the rest of the image to be in painted. And it looks really cool. Yeah.
of the qr code are almost unrecognizable because they've been surrounded by all this other content and it just seems to flow seamlessly um so yeah check out these qr codes they're pretty cool uh you know check out on the show notes get grab a link and take a look at them. It uses something called a control net, which I haven't done research on. But my guess is you fix the actual pixels that need to be black and white. You fix those or at least some percent of them. And then you allow the rest of the image to be in painted. And it looks really cool. Yeah.|||二维码的像素几乎无法辨认，因为它们被所有这些其他内容包围着，而且看起来无缝融合。嗯，所以，去看看这些二维码吧，它们相当酷。嗯，你知道的，去节目笔记里看看，获取一个链接并看一看它们。它使用了一种叫做 ControlNet 的技术，我还没对它进行研究。但我的猜测是，你固定了需要变成黑白的实际像素。你固定了这些像素，或者至少固定了其中的一部分。然后你允许图像的其余部分进行内绘（in-painting）。看起来真的很酷。是的。
So I, too, was like a little confused, but so Jason's right. It's basically you take like a QR code, which is very like binary range, like black and white block pixels, large chunks. If you add enough error correcting bits into it and then you basically like ignore that's a QR code and you paint a painting
So I, too, was like a little confused, but so Jason's right. It's basically you take like a QR code, which is very like binary range, like black and white block pixels, large chunks. If you add enough error correcting bits into it and then you basically like ignore that's a QR code and you paint a painting|||所以，我也觉得有点困惑，但杰森说得对。这基本上就是你拿一个二维码，它非常类似于二值范围，比如黑白方块像素、大块的区域。如果你在里面加入足够多的纠错位，然后你基本上就像是不去理会这是一个二维码，而是去画一幅画，
that happens to have light and dark splotches in approximately the right area. And you run it through a low pass filter. Right. You like get your phone far enough away. The idea is that like the light and dark and thresholding that you can get it there. Now, it seemed the people were saying that only some percentage of them actually end up working. Like it's not a very controlled things. You have to kind of experiment a bit.
that happens to have light and dark splotches in approximately the right area. And you run it through a low pass filter. Right. You like get your phone far enough away. The idea is that like the light and dark and thresholding that you can get it there. Now, it seemed the people were saying that only some percentage of them actually end up working. Like it's not a very controlled things. You have to kind of experiment a bit.|||而这幅画恰好在差不多正确的区域有明暗斑块。然后你通过一个低通滤波器处理它。对。你把手机拿得足够远。其理念是，光线、明暗和阈值处理能让你在那里识别出它。现在，人们似乎在说，其中只有一定比例的二维码最终能真正起作用。这并不是一个非常可控的事情。你必须进行一些实验。
And then Jason and I were talking as well, which we forget is sort of, I guess it's kind of like the hash collision attack that you could also do the same input or change parts of the URL that don't matter, like capitalize letters in the URL, which are ignored, like HTTP, big H, little t little t t p you know little h big t little t you know sort of like scramble the inputs to to get slightly different qr codes to try to find one
And then Jason and I were talking as well, which we forget is sort of, I guess it's kind of like the hash collision attack that you could also do the same input or change parts of the URL that don't matter, like capitalize letters in the URL, which are ignored, like HTTP, big H, little t little t t p you know little h big t little t you know sort of like scramble the inputs to to get slightly different qr codes to try to find one|||然后杰森和我也在讨论，我们忘记了这有点像是——我想这有点像哈希冲突攻击，你也可以使用相同的输入，或者更改 URL 中无关紧要的部分，比如将 URL 中的字母大写，这些大写字母会被忽略，比如大写的 H、小写的 t、小写的 t、p，你知道的，小写的 h、大写的 t、小写的 t，你知道的，有点像打乱输入，以获得略有不同的二维码，试图找到一个
that maybe works a little bit better um and so kind of an interesting thing but i could that that's sort of very interesting to me that like imagine a graffiti artist like putting one up on the side of a building and getting close enough. And like, you go to take a picture of it, you realize this picture, it didn't even look like a QR code. It's also a QR code.
that maybe works a little bit better um and so kind of interesting thing but i could that that's sort of very interesting to me that like imagine a graffiti artist like putting one up on the side of a building and getting close enough. And like, you go to take a picture of it, you realize this picture, it didn't even look like a QR code. It's also a QR code.|||可能运作得更好的二维码。嗯，所以这是一件挺有趣的事情，但我可以……这对我来说非常有趣，比如想象一个涂鸦艺术家把一个这样的二维码贴在建筑物的侧面，然后你走近去拍照。当你去拍一张照片时，你意识到这张照片甚至看起来不像一个二维码。它同时也是一个二维码。
Like, Oh, I could be super cool. Oh man, that is such a good idea. Yeah. And you could also take a QR reader library and do a closed loop thing where you generate the photo,
Like, Oh, I could be super cool. Oh man, that is such a good idea. Yeah. And you could also take a QR reader library and do a closed loop thing where you generate the photo,|||就像是，哦，我可以酷毙了。天哪，这真是个好主意。是的。你还可以拿一个二维码识别库，做一个闭环的事情，你生成照片，
you run it through maybe 10 QR reader libraries. Unless all 10 of them find the URL, you generate another one. Just keep trying. Keep tweaking. Really cool. I think those kinds of like, not like transformative uses, but also like you were kind of saying, like, it's just a matter of time and permutations. It's like what computers are really good at. Like, let it just struggle trying. Like a human would give up oh i painted this
you run it through maybe 10 QR reader libraries. Unless all 10 of them find the URL, you generate another one. Just keep trying. Keep tweaking. Really cool. I think those kinds of like, not like transformative uses, but also like you were kind of saying, like, it's just a matter of time and permutations. It's like what computers are really good at. Like, let it just struggle trying. Like a human would give up oh i painted this|||把它放进大约 10 个二维码识别库里运行。除非所有这 10 个库都能找到 URL，否则你就再生成一个。一直尝试。不断调整。真的很酷。我认为那种……不是那种变革性的用途，但也像你刚才所说的，这只是一个时间和排列组合的问题。这就像是计算机非常擅长的事情。就像，让它去不断尝试。人类会放弃，心想：哦，我画了这幅
painting and it failed your like arbitrary benchmark screw you like give me my money uh but like a computer will just sit there and try for what you know a year like six months whatever who cares like until you find a picture you like and that passes your benchmarks i have a bit of a spoiler if you've ever played this game, but there's this game called Chrono Trigger that came out in the 90s. It's like an RPG game. And there's this, you go back and forth through time, right?
painting and it failed your like arbitrary benchmark screw you like give me my money uh but like a computer will just sit there and try for what you know a year like six months whatever who cares like until you find a picture you like and that passes your benchmarks i have a bit of a spoiler if you've ever played this game, but there's this game called Chrono Trigger that came out in the 90s. It's like an RPG game. And there's this, you go back and forth through time, right?|||画，它没有达到你那随心所欲的基准，去你的，把钱还给我。呃，但计算机就会坐在那里尝试，你知道的，一年、六个月、随便多久，谁在乎呢，直到找到一张你喜欢并且能通过你的基准的图片。如果你玩过这个游戏的话，我这里有点剧透，有一款 90 年代发售的游戏叫《时空之轮》（Chrono Trigger）。这是一款 RPG 游戏。里面有这样的情节，你可以在时间里来回穿梭，对吧？
That's the chrono part of the Chrono Trigger. And so there's this one part where, I'm going to get this wrong because it's been so long, but basically there's this desert. And the desert desert like somehow you feel like you need to like bring life to the desert i don't remember why but but the way you do it is you have a robot who's like one of the characters in your party and all the characters have like they're really interesting dynamic characters they have good dialogue and so what you figure out is to take the robot to the desert in the beginning of time and leave him there and then go to the end of time.
That's the chrono part of the Chrono Trigger. And so there's this one part where, I'm going to get this wrong because it's been so long, but basically there's this desert. And the desert desert like somehow you feel like you need to like bring life to the desert i don't remember why but but the way you do it is you have a robot who's like one of the characters in your party and all the characters have like they're really interesting dynamic characters they have good dialogue and so what you figure out is to take the robot to the desert in the beginning of time and leave him there and then go to the end of time.|||这就是《时空之轮》中“时空（Chrono）”的由来。所以其中有一段——因为时间太久了，我可能会记错——但基本上有一个沙漠。那个沙漠……不知怎么的，你觉得你需要给沙漠带来生机，我不记得为什么了，但你实现这一点的方法是，你有一个机器人，他是你队伍中的角色之一，所有的角色都有……他们是非常有趣的动态角色，有着很好的对话。所以你想到的办法是，把机器人带到时间开端的沙漠里，把他留在那里，然后前往时间的尽头。
And he's like still curating the desert, except now it's like a tropical forest or something, right? And it just blew my mind. It's like, okay, now I realize like that whole, as a child, it kind of like hit me then. They're like, okay, I just went forward in time, but the robot experienced like 10,000 years of transformation or something. It's kind of like that. You can just let a computer go and come back to it
And he's like still curating the desert, except now it's like a tropical forest or something, right? And it just blew my mind. It's like, okay, now I realize like that whole, as a child, it kind of like hit me then. They're like, okay, I just went forward in time, but the robot experienced like 10,000 years of transformation or something. It's kind of like that. You can just let a computer go and come back to it|||他就像一直在照料那个沙漠，只不过现在那里变成了一个热带森林之类的，对吧？这简直让我大开眼界。就像是，好吧，现在我意识到，作为一个孩子，当时那种感觉深深震撼了我。他们就像是，好吧，我只是向前穿越了时间，但机器人经历了大约一万年的蜕变。这有点像那样。你可以直接让计算机去运行，然后过段时间再回来
after it's painted 10 million images. It's kind of a weird thing. My next topic is, I feel like maybe we've had this before, but it came up again. And it's a good one. So I'm doing it again. Anyways, learning to make digital music, which is sort of like beats, I guess. I don't know how to describe electronic music. Anyways, this is learningmusic.ableton.com, which Ableton is a digital audio workstation, a doc. So this is like one of my like lingering like I love watching YouTube videos. I tried every so often terrible at it. But how like teaching the
after it's painted 10 million images. It's kind of a weird thing. My next topic is, I feel like maybe we've had this before, but it came up again. And it's a good one. So I'm doing it again. Anyways, learning to make digital music, which is sort of like beats, I guess. I don't know how to describe electronic music. Anyways, this is learningmusic.ableton.com, which Ableton is a digital audio workstation, a doc. So this is like one of my like lingering like I love watching YouTube videos. I tried every so often terrible at it. But how like teaching the|||在它画了 1000 万张图片之后。这真是一件奇怪的事情。我的下一个话题是，我觉得我们以前可能讨论过这个，但它又出现了。而且这是一个很好的话题。所以我再讲一次。总之，学习制作数字音乐，这有点像节奏，我猜。我不知道该如何描述电子音乐。总之，这是 learningmusic.ableton.com，其中的 Ableton 是一个数字音频工作站（DAW）。所以这就像是我挥之不去的一个爱好——我喜欢看 YouTube 视频。我时不时会尝试一下，虽然做得很烂。但它如何像是在教授
structure of music, right? So you have like the underlying beats, you have a melody. And the web page is just really cool just to like play around. This is awesome. Little snippets of this DAW workflow in there so you know a grid pattern where you have four bars and then each row so it kind of looks like a matrix I guess like the top row is a hi-hat the next row is a clap sound the next row is a snare drum the next row is a bass drum and you're clicking in the squares and sort of programming how the the drum track sounds and then you have vertical bars to
structure of music, right? So you have like the underlying beats, you have a melody. And the web page is just really cool just to like play around. This is awesome. Little snippets of this DAW workflow in there so you know a grid pattern where you have four bars and then each row so it kind of looks like a matrix I guess like the top row is a hi-hat the next row is a clap sound the next row is a snare drum the next row is a bass drum and you're clicking in the squares and sort of programming how the the drum track sounds and then you have vertical bars to|||音乐的结构，对吧？所以你有底层节奏，有旋律。这个网页用起来真的很酷，可以随便玩玩。这太棒了。里面有这个 DAW 工作流程的小片段，所以你知道有一个网格模式，你有四小节，然后每一行——所以它看起来有点像一个矩阵，我猜，比如第一行是踩镲（hi-hat），下一行是拍手声，下一行是小军鼓，下一行是大军鼓，你在方框里点击，并以此来编程鼓轨听起来是怎样的，然后你有垂直的条用来
represent notes on a music staff i guess and then you know you're programming the melody and it's sort of teaching you kind of like the components and the structures i will say i did do most of it and it doesn't really teach you like good music it just teaches you like the structure so if you had a music in your head you could like learn how to put it into the computer but i don't have the music in my head so that part's a little bit missing um but yeah definitely check it out yeah super cool easy way to play around with you know show kids like it's very i would say like an intuitive learning experience i have the same thing where like i don't understand how they came up with this pattern and why that sounds good.
represent notes on a music staff i guess and then you know you're programming the melody and it's sort of teaching you kind of like the components and the structures i will say i did do most of it and it doesn't really teach you like good music it just teaches you like the structure so if you had a music in your head you could like learn how to put it into the computer but i don't have the music in my head so that part's a little bit missing um but yeah definitely check it out yeah super cool easy way to play around with you know show kids like it's very i would say like an intuitive learning experience i have the same thing where like i don't understand how they came up with this pattern and why that sounds good.|||表示五线谱上的音符，我猜，然后你知道你在编写旋律，它有点像是在教你组件和结构。我得说我确实做完了大部分内容，它其实并没有教你写出好音乐，它只是教你结构。所以如果你的脑海里有音乐，你就可以学会如何把它输入到电脑里，但我脑海里没有音乐，所以这部分有点缺失。嗯，不过是的，一定要去看看。是的，超级酷，这是一种轻松的游玩方式，你知道的，展示给孩子们看，这是一个非常……我要说这是一个直观的学习体验。我有同感，就像我搞不懂他们是怎么想出这个音符模式的，以及为什么这样听起来很好听。
But yeah, this is, I love stuff like this. So if you wanted to make mediocre to bad music and you're me, this will teach you how to do it. Nice. Yeah, no, this is amazing. You definitely got to play with this. Yeah, I think this is great for kids too. Very accessible.
But yeah, this is, I love stuff like this. So if you wanted to make mediocre to bad music and you're me, this will teach you how to do it. Nice. Yeah, no, this is amazing. You definitely got to play with this. Yeah, I think this is great for kids too. Very accessible.|||但是，是的，我就是喜欢这样的东西。所以如果你想做出平庸到糟糕的音乐，而你又恰好是我，这会教你该怎么做。不错。是的，不，这太棒了。你绝对得玩玩这个。是的，我觉得这对孩子们也很好。非常容易上手。
You just click on these boxes and it will add more, like change the sound. Cool. All right. My next topic is GPT for all. There's probably a temporary name because I know OpenAI has been trying to sue anyone who has GPT in their name. Oh, really? But GPT for all is a desktop application. You install it on your desktop and it has a list of open source, you know, chat engines. And so you pick an engine or pick multiple engines. And then now you have
You just click on these boxes and it will add more, like change the sound. Cool. All right. My next topic is GPT for all. There's probably a temporary name because I know OpenAI has been trying to sue anyone who has GPT in their name. Oh, really? But GPT for all is a desktop application. You install it on your desktop and it has a list of open source, you know, chat engines. And so you pick an engine or pick multiple engines. And then now you have|||你只需点击这些方块，它就会添加更多内容，比如改变声音。酷。好的。我的下一个话题是 GPT for all。这可能是一个临时的名字，因为我知道 OpenAI 一直在试图起诉任何名字中带有 GPT 的人。哦，真的吗？但 GPT for all 是一个桌面应用程序。你把它安装在桌面上，它有一个开源的、你知道的聊天引擎列表。然后你选择一个引擎或多个引擎。接着现在你就拥有了
like a GPT on your desktop and it's all local. Once you download the engine, you don't have to download anything else. And so I had a bunch of questions. One thing I noticed with the open source ones is you have to kind of cheat a little bit. So instead of just saying, like, you know, who built the Eiffel Tower? You actually have to say, question, colon, who built the Eiffel Tower, new line, answer, colon.
like a GPT on your desktop and it's all local. Once you download the engine, you don't have to download anything else. And so I had a bunch of questions. One thing I noticed with the open source ones is you have to kind of cheat a little bit. So instead of just saying, like, you know, who built the Eiffel Tower? You actually have to say, question, colon, who built the Eiffel Tower, new line, answer, colon.|||一个运行在桌面上的 GPT，而且完全是本地的。一旦你下载了引擎，你就不需要下载其他任何东西了。所以我有一堆问题。我注意到开源模型的一点是，你必须稍微作弊一下。所以，与其只说“你知道的，谁建造了埃菲尔铁塔？”，你实际上必须说：“问题：谁建造了埃菲尔铁塔”，然后换行，写上“回答：”。
And if you do that, then it knows. If you don't, then these language models will just go off the rails. We actually talked about this with Hagai in that episode. So if you missed the generative AI large language model episode that we just did, definitely go back and give that one a listen. But this is really, really cool. It runs totally on your desktop. It runs basically real time.
And if you do that, then it knows. If you don't, then these language models will just go off the rails. We actually talked about this with Hagai in that episode. So if you missed the generative AI large language model episode that we just did, definitely go back and give that one a listen. But this is really, really cool. It runs totally on your desktop. It runs basically real time.|||如果你这样做，它就知道了。如果你不这样做，这些语言模型就会彻底失控。我们在那一期的节目中实际上和哈盖（Hagai）讨论过这个问题。所以如果你错过了我们刚刚制作的生成式人工智能大语言模型那一期，一定要回去听听那一期。但这真的非常非常酷。它完全在你的桌面上运行。它基本上是实时运行的。
Like it's generating one or two words a second. And I really enjoyed this. I think if we could get it on a phone, that would be even better. I'm sure they're working on it. I saw as well, so there's this tool for gluing together a lot of these things called Langchain.
Like it's generating one or two words a second. And I really enjoyed this. I think if we could get it on a phone, that would be even better. I'm sure they're working on it. I saw as well, so there's this tool for gluing together a lot of these things called Langchain.|||就像它每秒生成一两个词一样。我真的很喜欢这个。我想如果我们能把它弄到手机上，那就更好了。我确信他们正在为此努力。我还看到，有一个用于将许多这些东西粘合在一起的工具叫做 Langchain。
Do you know about this oh no i haven't heard of that okay so somehow i ended up in my like youtube feed and i watched like a few videos about and i keep getting random like how to make money by generating you know various like uh print on demand amazon books using ai okay so this lang chain is a way of doing the stuff that we've been talking about, but gluing it all together. So you want to take text and run the embedding on it so that you can search a vector database. So you want to use OpenAI to do the embedding, put in your token and it'll help you. Now they're actually producing, I guess we would call them WYSIWYG or non-coding ways of
Do you know about this oh no i haven't heard of that okay so somehow i ended up in my like youtube feed and i watched like a few videos about and i keep getting random like how to make money by generating you know various like uh print on demand amazon books using ai okay so this lang chain is a way of doing the stuff that we've been talking about, but gluing it all together. So you want to take text and run the embedding on it so that you can search a vector database. So you want to use OpenAI to do the embedding, put in your token and it'll help you. Now they're actually producing, I guess we would call them WYSIWYG or non-coding ways of|||你知道这个吗？哦，没有，我没听说过。好吧，不知怎么的，它出现在我的 YouTube 信息流里，我看了几段关于它的视频，然后我不断收到随机的推荐，比如如何通过 AI 生成各种按需打印的亚马逊书籍来赚钱。好吧，这个 Langchain 是做我们一直在谈论的事情的一种方法，但它是把这一切粘合在一起。所以你想获取文本并在其上运行嵌入（embedding），以便你可以搜索向量数据库。所以你想用 OpenAI 来进行嵌入，输入你的令牌（token），它就会帮助你。现在他们实际上在生产，我想我们可以称之为所见即所得（WYSIWYG）或非编码的方式，
just dragging, connecting the boxes together. So if you wanted to like run multiple open source generators and how would you combine them? And so there's little blocks and you're dragging the blocks around. And so we've talked about before, like if you want to ask a question like against a corpus, how do you ingest that corpus? So there's like ingester. So like, oh, I want all hacker news articles and links and comments to like go into something. So if I'm searching for what's a good C++ tool to do debugging, right, then like all the hacker news corpus is in there. And so
just dragging, connecting the boxes together. So if you wanted to like run multiple open source generators and how would you combine them? And so there's little blocks and you're dragging the blocks around. And so we've talked about before, like if you want to ask a question like against a corpus, how do you ingest that corpus? So there's like ingester. So like, oh, I want all hacker news articles and links and comments to like go into something. So if I'm searching for what's a good C++ tool to do debugging, right, then like all the hacker news corpus is in there. And so|||只需拖动、将方框连接在一起。所以如果你想运行多个开源生成器，你将如何组合它们？这里有小方块，你可以拖动这些方块。正如我们以前讨论过的，如果你想针对一个语料库提出问题，你如何摄取该语料库？所以有一个类似于摄取器的东西。就像，哦，我想要所有 Hacker News 的文章、链接和评论都进入某个东西中。所以如果我在搜索有什么好的 C++ 调试工具，对吧，那么所有 Hacker News 的语料库都在里面了。所以
they have these blocks, and you can kind of just plop them down and connect them. Community is just moving super, super fast around like how to connect all these up, how to do this hybrid workflow in a way I've not really seen before, where like, oh, I might send my tokens up to, you know, OpenAI's tokenizer and better, but then locally I may, you know, do this text parsing and the splitting and this sort of cloud local hybrid
they have these blocks, and you can kind of just plop them down and connect them. Community is just moving super, super fast around like how to connect all these up, how to do this hybrid workflow in a way I've not really seen before, where like, oh, I might send my tokens up to, you know, OpenAI's tokenizer and better, but then locally I may, you know, do this text parsing and the splitting and this sort of cloud local hybrid|||他们有这些方块，你基本上只需把它们放下并连接起来即可。社区在如何将所有这些连接起来、如何以一种我以前从未见过的方式进行这种混合工作流方面，发展得超级、超级快。比如，哦，我可能会把我的令牌发送到，你知道的，OpenAI 的分词器和嵌入器，但在本地我可能，你知道的，进行这种文本解析和分割，这种云端与本地的混合
is really interesting to see evolving. Yeah, totally. I know that there's also been a ton of work on trying to get these models to run on all sorts of different hardware and figuring out what concessions you can make. I was amazed to see the four-bit quantization. Whoa. You only have 16 values for each weight in the neural net after you're done training it. And that still works really, really well.
is really interesting to see evolving. Yeah, totally. I know that there's also been a ton of work on trying to get these models to run on all sorts of different hardware and figuring out what concessions you can make. I was amazed to see the four-bit quantization. Whoa. You only have 16 values for each weight in the neural net after you're done training it. And that still works really, really well.|||看着它不断演变真的很有趣。是的，完全同意。我知道也有大量的工作在试图让这些模型在各种不同的硬件上运行，并弄清楚你可以做出哪些妥协。看到 4 位量化（four-bit quantization）时我惊呆了。哇。在完成训练后，神经网络中每个权重只有 16 个可选值。而这仍然运行得非常非常出色。
So yeah, that blew my mind. Oh, I see this. I'm going to check this out later. I would not have assumed it could go that low. Yeah. Yeah, it's wild. Yeah, I wonder, you know, honestly, I feel like this gets back to the thing we talked about with Hagai, where there's just not enough data to satisfy these huge models. I almost wonder if maybe they could even do the quantization
So yeah, that blew my mind. Oh, I see this. I'm going to check this out later. I would not have assumed it could go that low. Yeah. Yeah, it's wild. Yeah, I wonder, you know, honestly, I feel like this gets back to the thing we talked about with Hagai, where there's just not enough data to satisfy these huge models. I almost wonder if maybe they could even do the quantization|||所以，是的，这让我大开眼界。哦，我看到了这个。我待会儿去看看。我以前绝不会想到它能降得那么低。是的。是的，这太疯狂了。是的，我在想，老实说，我觉得这又回到了我们和哈盖讨论过的事情，即没有足够的数据来满足这些庞大的模型。我甚至在想，也许他们甚至可以在
during training. It would be even better. All right, time for book of the show. What's your book of the show, Patrick? Mine is a graphic novel by an author I recommended probably 75% of the time. But anyways, Brandon Sanderson and the graphic novel is white sand and in this sort of same universe as a lot of his other works, but actually interestingly, the graphic novel. So I have this, I read the graphic novel.
during training. It would be even better. All right, time for book of the show. What's your book of the show, Patrick? Mine is a graphic novel by an author I recommended probably 75% of the time. But anyways, Brandon Sanderson and the graphic novel is white sand and in this sort of same universe as a lot of his other works, but actually interestingly, the graphic novel. So I have this, I read the graphic novel.|||训练期间进行量化。那会更好。好了，到了本期图书推荐时间。帕特里克，你本期推荐的书是什么？我的是一本图像小说（graphic novel），作者是我大概在 75% 的时间里都会推荐的那位。但无论如何，布兰登·桑德森（Brandon Sanderson），这部图像小说是《白沙》（White Sand），它和他的许多其他作品处于某种相同的宇宙中，但实际上有趣的是，这是一部图像小说。所以我有这个，我读了这本图像小说。
It is good, but I did something which I had not done before, which is I've talked about before doing audio books. So audio books have a graphic novel, a bit weird. Yeah, which is I've talked about before doing audio books. So audio books of a graphic novel a bit weird. Yeah, sure. I get it. But I did a specific which is like a visual audio book. What is it called? And what it does is instead of just one single narrator, sort of graphic audio, there we go is the sort of like specific group that did this one. rather than just a single narrator reading or like you know two narrators they have like the sound effects like oh you know so and so was walking across the sand okay i'm doing terrible that's like the old
It is good, but I did something which I had not done before, which is I've talked about before doing audio books. So audio books have a graphic novel, a bit weird. Yeah, sure. I get it. But I did a specific which is like a visual audio book. What is it called? And what it does is instead of just one single narrator, sort of graphic audio, there we go is the sort of like specific group that did this one. rather than just a single narrator reading or like you know two narrators they have like the sound effects like oh you know so and so was walking across the sand okay i'm doing terrible that's like the old|||它很不错，但我做了一件我以前没做过的事，那就是我之前谈论过有声书。所以有声书里有一部图像小说，有点奇怪。是的，当然。我明白。但我做了一件具体的事情，就像是一个视觉有声书。它叫什么来着？它的作用是，它不仅仅是一个单一的旁白，而是类似于有声图像剧（graphic audio），对了，这就是制作这个作品的那个特定团队。不仅仅是一个旁白在朗读，或者你知道的两个旁白，他们有音效，比如：哦，你知道的，某某正在穿过沙漠……好吧，我模仿得太差了，这就像是老式的
radio like radio era yes and so they they kind of did audio books for this novel and i listened to it with my kids and it was sort of like a little bit more immersive for them to kind of did audio books for this novel and i listened to it with my kids and it was sort of like a little bit more immersive for them to kind of like hear the you know walking across the desert and the wind is swirling and you know you hear the sound of the wind i some people probably find it really annoying but also every character has their own voice actor doing it so not just someone having a slightly different voice but actually like it's a full cast does the whole thing it's really cool. And this is the first time I listened to it.
像广播电台时代的广播，对，他们为这本小说做了某种有声书，我和我的孩子们一起听的。对他们来说，这更有沉浸感，比如听到，你知道的，走过沙漠的声音，风在呼呼地吹，你知道的，你能听到风声。有些人可能会觉得这真的很烦人，但每个角色都有自己的配音演员来演绎，不仅仅是声音稍微有点不同，而是真正的全配音阵容来完成整部作品，真的很酷。而且这是我第一次听。
So the book was good, yes. But also this particular presentation style was pretty legit. I liked it. You know, now that you mention it, there is no generative AI for sounds yet. Like you can't type in, you know, feet crunching on the ground and get an MP3. But if you could get to it man before
所以这本书很不错，是的。但这种特定的呈现风格也相当不错。我很喜欢。你知道的，经你这么一说，现在还没有用于声音的生成式AI。就像你不能输入，你知道的，脚踩在地面上的声音然后得到一个MP3。但如果你能在
the podcast comes out you had to hurry but you i mean imagine if you did that then you could take old audio books and add sound effects to them what sound effects would get added to our podcast jason no i'm snoring a podcast it would uh who knows? It would be maybe we put a laugh track in. Every time we do our like book of the show, you would get some sort of jingle. Yeah, that's right. But no, I think for things that are atmospheric, right? Like books that have world building and stuff that could be really neat. That'd be cool.
播客发布之前搞定，你就得抓紧时间了，我的意思是，想象一下如果你那样做了，你就可以拿旧的有声书并为它们添加音效。会给我们的播客添加什么音效呢，杰森？不，我在打呼噜，这个播客会，呃，谁知道呢？可能会加入笑声音轨。每次我们推出像“本期图书”这样的环节时，你都会听到某种叮咚声。是的，没错。不过说真的，我觉得对于有氛围感的东西，对吧？比如那些有世界观构建的书籍，那可能会非常棒。那会很酷。
My book of the show is a total bit of foreshadowing here. It is an interactive fiction book that I wrote. And so you can go to generativefiction.com and you can play this interactive fiction game and we'll talk about it in the actual show. But I've always wanted to make one of these. This is how I got into computers. My very first computer, my parents actually were in the classified ads.
我这期的推荐图书这里其实是一个十足的伏笔。它是我写的一本互动小说。所以你可以访问 generativefiction.com，然后你可以玩这个互动小说游戏，我们会在正节目中讨论它。但我一直想制作这样的一部作品。这就是我接触计算机的原因。我的第一台计算机，其实是我父母在分类广告里看到的。
They had this really nerdy kid and they didn't know what to do with him. And they were in the classified ads and saw this person was giving away, not giving away, but they were selling a computer. So they contacted this person. It was this old gentleman. He said, sure, you know. And so he actually came over to our house uh like actually drove to our house with a commodore 64 and he set it all up and he showed me all these games that he had bought over the years and everything and and this one game had a hardcover manual and i thought that was you know really interesting and so he was explaining how yeah
他们有一个非常极客的孩子，不知道该拿他怎么办。他们在分类广告里看到有人在转让，不是免费转让，而是在卖一台计算机。于是他们联系了这个人。那是一位老绅士。他说，当然可以，你知道的。于是他真的来到了我们家里，呃，真的开车带着一台康莫度 64 (Commodore 64) 来到我们家，他把一切都设置好了，向我展示了他这些年来买的各种游戏，还有所有这些东西，而且其中一个游戏有一本精装手册，我觉得，你知道的，这真的很有趣，于是他解释说，是的，
you got it's actually a book you read you literally read this 50 70 page hardcover book and then the last chapter of the book like it's not over it just switches to the video game and uh so that's how i really got into pretty much everything. And so it's true. You read this book, you get to like chapter, whatever it is. And then it's the end of the chapter. It's like, okay,
你明白了，其实这是一本你要读的书，你真的要去读这本 50 到 70 页的精装书，然后书的最后一章，就像它还没结束一样，直接切换到了电子游戏，呃，所以这就是我真正接触到几乎所有一切的开始。所以这是真的。你读这本书，读到第几章，随便哪一章。然后这一章就结束了。就像是，好的，
put in the first disc and the game just picks up where the book left off, except now you can, you know, take actions and stuff. So it was really magical. And so, you know, I thought I've always wanted to do this.
放入第一张磁盘，游戏就会从书本结束的地方接着开始，只不过现在你可以，你知道的，采取行动之类的了。所以这真的很神奇。因此，你知道的，我想我一直都想做这样的东西。
It ended up being easier in some ways, harder in other ways, but I was able to pull off a little generative fiction book of my own. Very cool. Yeah. Go ahead and folks can check it out. Also, check out the show. We love creating stuff for our audience.
结果证明它在某些方面更容易，在另一些方面更难，但我还是成功地创作出了一本属于我自己的小型生成式小说。非常酷。是的。大家可以去看一看。另外，也去看看这个节目。我们喜欢为我们的听众创作内容。
Love doing the book, the show. If you want to support the show and all the work that we do, you can support us on Patreon. Go to patreon.com slash programmingthrowdown. And with that, it's time for Tool of the Show. My tool of the show is gatsby.js.
喜欢做书，做节目。如果你想支持这个节目以及我们所做的所有工作，你可以在 Patreon 上支持我们。访问 patreon.com/programmingthrowdown。接下来，是本期工具环节。我这期推荐的工具是 gatsby.js。
If you go to programmingthrowdown.com, you'll see it looks totally different. That's because I rewrote it. And so I used Gatsby for that. Gatsby is really, really interesting. I've been wanting to build something with it for a long time. And the way it works is
如果你访问 programmingthrowdown.com，你会发现它看起来完全不同了。那是因为我重写了它。所以我为此使用了 Gatsby。Gatsby 真的非常有趣。我一直想用它构建一些东西，已经很久了。它的工作方式是
it has a series of data sources. And so what it will do is it will automatically generate a GraphQL API for your data sources. But all of this happens at compile time. So like when you're when you say, you know, Gatsby build, it does a bunch of stuff. And at the end, you just get some static HTML and JavaScript. But what it does is it actually, when you say Gatsby build, it starts up a server, a GraphQL server. It connects that server to all of your data, which could be JSON files in your computer. It could be a database.
它有一系列数据源。所以它会做的是，它会为你的数据源自动生成一个 GraphQL API。但所有这一切都发生在编译时。所以就像当你输入，你知道的，“Gatsby build”时，它会做一堆事情。最后，你只会得到一些静态的 HTML 和 JavaScript。但它的作用实际上是，当你输入 Gatsby build 时，它会启动一个服务器，一个 GraphQL 服务器。它将该服务器连接到你的所有数据，这些数据可以是计算机中的 JSON 文件。它可以是一个数据库。
It could be a content management service, which is something we should talk about in another show. But it connects to all of these things. And then it says, OK, I'm ready. Ask me questions about your site. And then it starts going through all of your dot HTML and dot JavaScript files and, you know, getting queries out of those files, executing those queries and then putting the data in. So, for example, you know, I have a JavaScript file, which is like, you know, parentheses, episode, close parentheses. There's like parentheses, like show dot episode close parentheses dot js like that's the name of the file and it's kind of a weird name of a file but gatsby uses the file name to figure out like what should go there and because it has a parentheses you're telling gatsby there's going to be actually a lot of these so So I want you to run this query, like show.episode.
它可以是一个内容管理服务，这是我们在另一个节目中应该讨论的事情。但它连接到所有这些东西，然后它说，好的，我准备好了。问我关于你网站的问题。然后它开始遍历你所有的点 HTML 和点 JavaScript 文件，你知道的，从这些文件中获取查询，执行这些查询然后把数据放进去。所以，例如，你知道的，我有一个 JavaScript 文件，就像是，你知道的，括号，episode，闭括号。就像是括号，像 show 点 episode 闭括号点 js，这就是文件名，这有点像一个奇怪的文件名，但 Gatsby 使用文件名来弄清楚什么应该放在那里，因为有一个括号，你是在告诉 Gatsby 实际上会有很多这样的文件，所以我希望你运行这个查询，比如 show.episode。
And if you get back 100 results, I actually want 100 web pages. And Gatsby will do all of this for you. And what you end up with at the end is this static site that you can put on GitHub. You can host it on S3, Amazon Storage. It doesn't need a server at that point. It just needs a way to transfer these files to your browser. So yeah, I was really impressed by it. It even has a search.
如果你返回 100 个结果，我实际上想要 100 个网页。Gatsby 会为你完成所有这一切。最后你得到的是一个可以放在 GitHub 上的静态网站。你可以把它托管在 S3 上，即亚马逊存储。它在那个时候不需要服务器。它只需要一种将这些文件传输到你的浏览器的方法。所以，是的，我对它印象深刻。它甚至还有一个搜索功能。
So you can go to programmingthrowdown.com and you can search for C++ or Java or whatever you want, and you'll get all the episodes where we talk about these things. And that entire search is running in your browser, like the search engine, the entire search database is downloaded to your browser when you do a search. Really amazing technology. I was really satisfied by it. And I would recommend if you're building a site like that, definitely start with Gatsby.
所以你可以访问 programmingthrowdown.com，你可以搜索 C++ 或 Java 或任何你想要的东西，你会得到我们讨论这些东西的所有剧集。整个搜索都是在你的浏览器中运行的，就像搜索引擎一样，当你进行搜索时，整个搜索数据库都会被下载到你的浏览器中。真的令人惊叹的技术。我对它非常满意。如果你在构建这样的网站，我绝对推荐从 Gatsby 开始。
I was really impressed. I think Next.js is what I used to build the Fortuna site and that's because that needs to be a lot more client server so you know Gatsby is not for everything but if you need just a static website I was super impressed by what it does very cool my tool of the show is a game continuing my longstanding tradition of wasting everyone's time. And this game is Pagelin. Pagelin is available on PC, Android and iOS. I think on iOS, which is how I was playing it, it's free to download and get effectively a demo. And then if you want to like play more levels, then I believe it was like $9,
我真的很印象深刻。我想 Next.js 是我用来构建 Fortuna 网站的工具，那是因为它需要更多的客户端服务器交互，所以你知道 Gatsby 并不是万能的，但如果你只需要一个静态网站，我对它的功能超级印象深刻。非常酷。我这期推荐的工具是一款游戏，延续了我长期以来浪费大家时间的传统。这款游戏叫 Pagelin。Pagelin 在 PC、Android 和 iOS 上都可以玩。我想在 iOS 上，也就是我玩它的方式，它是免费下载的，实际上可以玩到的是一个演示版。然后如果你想玩更多关卡，我想价格大概是 9 美元，
which is a little expensive for a game, but I think the normal default price on Steam is like $20. So the mobile discount, I guess. And this game is a play on Pachinko and a roguelike, which is a crazy combination. Okay, what is Pachinko? You have to explain this. Pachinko is a Japanese game where the metal marbles fall in the top and there's various pegs or like spinners uh so kind of like a pinball machine except you can't push
对于一个游戏来说有点贵，但我认为它在 Steam 上的正常默认价格大约是 20 美元。所以我想这是移动端折扣吧。这款游戏结合了弹珠台 (Pachinko) 和 Roguelike，这是一个疯狂的组合。好吧，什么是弹珠台？你得解释一下这个。弹珠台是一种日本游戏，金属弹珠从顶部落下，里面有各种钉子或旋转器，呃，有点像弹球机，只是你不能把
the pinballs back up so they sort of bounce around and fall down through various obstacles and so you have some uh your your sort of uh ball bearings that go in through the top you can control sort of the angle they come in at there's sort of like an angle selection and then there's various types which is the rogue-like element so they have various stats and then you have enemies coming at you
弹球推回顶部，所以它们会在各种障碍物之间弹跳并落下来。所以你有一些，呃，你的，呃，滚珠从顶部进去，你可以控制它们进入的角度，有点像角度选择，然后有各种类型，这就是 Roguelike 元素，所以它们有各种属性，然后有敌人向你冲过来，
and so you need to launch into blocks that are on the screen which you will bounce around the screen and off of and eventually off the bottom of the screen and each kind of block you hit and the kind of ball you're launching the combination gives you sort of your attack or a healing ability or whatever and as you progress through sort of like the roguelike card games you can acquire new i don't remember what they call them stones new things that you launch that have different stats where you can upgrade them to get better stats uh and then the
所以你需要把它们发射到屏幕上的方块中，弹珠会在屏幕上弹来弹去，最后从屏幕底部弹出去。你击中的每一种块以及你发射的球的类型，这种组合会赋予你攻击或治疗能力等等。随着你在类 Roguelike 的卡牌游戏中不断推进，你可以获得新的——我不记得他们叫它们什么了——石头，你可以发射具有不同属性的新东西，或者你可以升级它们以获得更好的属性，然后
enemies are coming at you and it's again like a roguelike so eventually if you're not able to defeat the enemy before it gets to you they'll kill you and then you lose you're going to start over but each time you start you have like a little bit more of a head start until you can win yes it's basically the basically the progression the sort of standard uh formula there but seeing it applied to that style of game was a new one for me so i've been playing that and enjoying it that looks awesome um i used to love bust a move which is okay similar idea similar yeah yeah Same kind of vein. Yeah, actually, that's the one game that
敌人向你冲过来，这同样像 Roguelike 游戏一样，所以最终如果你在敌人接近你之前无法击败它，它们就会杀死你，然后你就会输，你得重新开始。但每次开始时，你都会有一点点领先优势，直到你能赢得胜利。是的，基本上就是这样，基本上是那种进程，那种标准的公式，但看到它应用到那种风格的游戏中对我是个新鲜体验。所以我一直在玩，并且很享受。这看起来太棒了，嗯，我以前很喜欢《Busta Move》(泡泡龙)，它，好吧，相似的想法，相似的，是的，是的。同样的路线。是的，实际上那是
my wife and I will play together. She's not a gamer at all, but she loves like Tetris and Busta Move and these games. We're pretty evenly matched. Pretty evenly matched, yeah. It's interesting because in that game one of us will get on a roll
我和我妻子会一起玩的唯一游戏。她根本不是个游戏玩家，但她喜欢像《俄罗斯方块》和《泡泡龙》这样的游戏。我们俩水平相当。水平相当，是的。很有趣，因为在那款游戏中，我们中的一个人会手感火热，
and just like the whole night just be like winning almost every single game, but it's interesting because in that game one of us will get on a roll and just like the whole night just be like like winning every almost every single game but it's it's uh sometimes she's on a roll sometimes i'm on a roll it uh it just kind of maybe depends on like whether you're in the zone or not i guess do you keep track of your like elo rating and like see you know infinity or divide by zero it doesn't work with only two people i guess yeah um all right on to the topic so patrick you have never played interactive fiction i oh you confessed my dirty secret i i have i played the first 30 seconds of hitchhiker's guide to the galaxy interactive fiction or the first five minutes and got immediately confused and sort of, sort of bombed my way out. frustrating like you kind of so there was a lot of uh a lot of bad design patterns in in a lot of
整晚几乎赢得每一场比赛，但这很有趣，因为在那款游戏中，我们中的一个人会手感火热，整晚几乎赢得每一场比赛，但它，呃，有时她手气好，有时我手气好，它，呃，可能只是取决于你当时是否进入状态吧。你会追踪你们的 Elo 评分之类的并看看，你知道的，无穷大还是除以零？只有两个人的时候这不管用吧。嗯，好的，进入正题。所以帕特里克，你从来没玩过互动小说？哦，你坦白了我的小秘密，我，我玩过《银河系漫游指南》互动小说的前 30 秒，或者前五分钟，然后立刻感到困惑，然后，呃，算是半途而废了。令人沮丧，因为你有点，所以有很多，呃，有很多不良的设计模式，在许多
interactive fiction games i think they've gotten better over the years like anything but but they definitely suffered from that you know one of the biggest anti-patterns in my opinion from interactive fiction is in a lot of them they they wanted you to kind of it's hard to generate the content right because you have to write the room descriptions you have to see you have to think about anticipate all the things a person could do in that room and like write answers for all of those things so let me let me kind of walk it back so interactive fiction is basically a text-based game. You write text to kind of advance the story or have your agent do things.
互动小说游戏中，我认为随着时间的推移它们已经变得越来越好，就像任何事物一样，但它们绝对深受其害，你知道的，在我看来，互动小说最大的反模式之一就是，在许多游戏中，它们希望你，呃，很难生成内容，对吧？因为你必须编写房间描述，你必须看到，你必须考虑并预测一个人在该房间里可能做出的所有事情，并为所有这些事情编写答案。所以让我，让我稍微退一步讲，所以互动小说基本上是一个基于文本的游戏。你通过输入文本来推进故事或让你的代理做事。
And in exchange, you get text feedback. And so for example, you can type look and you'll get a description of the room. You can type go north or open the door or pick up the torch and your character will kind of do these things. And so. As you can imagine, this is extremely open ended, right? I mean, think about Minecraft. In Minecraft, you can go left, you know, forward, backwards, right. You have an interact key that does all your interactions and then you have kill right and so that's basically i mean i know it's there's a lot of emergent behavior there but but on the surface the the action space is relatively small in this
作为回报，你会得到文本反馈。例如，你可以输入 look，然后你会得到房间的描述。你可以输入 go north 或 open the door 或 pick up the torch，你的角色就会做这些事情。所以。你可以想象，这是极其开放式的，对吧？我的意思是，想想《我的世界》(Minecraft)。在《我的世界》里，你可以向左，你知道的，向前，向后，向右。你有一个执行所有交互的交互键，然后你有 kill，所以基本上，我知道那里有很多涌现行为，但在表面上，动作空间相对较小。在这种情况下，
case you can type anything like the the game is supposed to let you type just about anything. And even though they try to guide you a certain way, and there's usually a help screen in the beginning that kind of gives you a list of suggested actions and a way to structure your inputs, it's still like extremely wide surface area. And so because of that, generating content is really time consuming and hard on disk space and all of that. And because of that, they would often kill your
你可以输入任何东西，比如游戏应该允许你输入几乎任何东西。尽管他们试图引导你走某种特定的路线，并且通常在开始时有一个帮助屏幕，为你提供建议操作的列表和构建输入的方法，但它仍然是，你知道的，极其宽广的表面积。正因为如此，生成内容非常耗时，对磁盘空间的要求也很高，等等。正因为如此，它们经常会杀死你的
character and make you start over. And so I don't know, I never played Hitchhiker's Guide, but in a lot of these games, you you know take some actions you would try something there was one game called amnesia and you wake up and the first thing you might want to do is walk out of the room so you type like open door walk out of the door and someone just comes and kills you that's like okay yeah that didn't work so you start over again so you realize okay you know i can't just walk out the door. I have to jump out the window or whatever. And you might get further along and then someone kills you.
角色并让你重新开始。所以，我不知道，我从未玩过《银河系漫游指南》，但在许多这样的游戏中，你，你知道的，采取一些行动，你会尝试一些东西，有一个游戏叫《失忆症》(Amnesia)，你醒来后，你可能想做的第一件事就是走出房间，所以你输入类似于 open door walk out of the door，然后有人直接走过来把你杀了，这就好比，好吧，是的，这行不通，所以你重新开始。所以你意识到，好吧，你知道的，我不能只是走出房门。我必须跳窗户或者别的什么。你可能会走得更远，然后有人把你杀了。
You have to start over. I think that the starting over just ruined it for a lot of people. Like that caused a lot of people not to be playing. Is that what happened to you, Patrick? Or was it different? Yeah, I think that's this thing you're saying it's like maybe i should just like read the strategy guide or something a little bit more but i try not to to not spoil it but then i don't know it's like what are the verbs that i can use like you know i'm playing some game like talk no you can't talk there's no one to talk to like
你不得不重新开始。我认为这种重新开始毁了很多人的体验。这导致很多人不再玩了。这就是发生在你身上的事吗，帕特里克？还是说情况不同？是的，我想就是你说的这种事情，可能我就应该稍微多读一点攻略指南之类的东西，但我尽量不去破坏游戏体验，但随后，我不知道，就像，我能用什么动词呢？你知道的，我在玩某个游戏，比如 talk，不，你不能 talk，没有人可以对话，就好像，
you know okay well i don't understand what i'm supposed to do like there's sort of something expected of me but i'm not sure like what is expected or uh it's sort of like you were describing minecraft like what is the point like i'm not clear that there's not a like overarching push for me to do a very specific thing and so i think i just needed to wrap my brain. I was expecting an experience more like, you know, Donkey Kong Country or Super Mario. It's like the game is scrolling left to right. It's very clear, you know, what I need to do. And here it was not.
你知道的，好吧，我不明白我应该做什么，就像有一种对我的期望，但我不太确定期望是什么，或者，呃，这有点像你刚才描述的《我的世界》，重点是什么？我不清楚是否存在一个宏伟的推动力让我去做一件非常具体的事情。所以我认为我只是需要理清自己的思路。我期待的体验更像是，你知道的，大金刚或超级马里奥。就像游戏是从左向右滚动的，你知道的，我需要做什么非常明确。而在这里并非如此。
It's, you know, three-dimensional time. So I guess four-dimensional and like, it's not clear how I'm supposed to proceed through the world or what order or, oh, I'm here and I clearly need a key, but I don't know where the key is so I need to go try every room scouring it for a key I don't know then I always sort of bail when there's like some grinding aspect yeah yep that makes sense I think you know colossal caves is one example of that where you pretty much can't you know make progress in that game without
这是，你知道的，三维时间。所以我想是四维的，并且，你知道的，不清楚我应该如何穿过世界，或者以什么顺序，或者，哦，我在这里，我显然需要一把钥匙，但我不知道钥匙在哪里，所以我需要去尝试每一个房间，搜寻一把我不知道在哪里的钥匙，然后每当有某种枯燥的刷怪环节时，我总是会选择放弃。是的，这说得通。我想，你知道的，《巨洞冒险》(Colossal Caves) 就是一个例子，在那里你几乎不可能，你知道的，在那个游戏中取得进展，除非
literally drawing your own map or nowadays downloading it from the internet and i just wasn't ready to like buy grid paper and start you know mapping out the game by hand so it just i never made it very far in that game but yeah i think the way the way that these games work always really fascinated me. As a really young child, I actually, you know, I was pretty sure that there wasn't a human, like there wasn't a human on the other end typing these answers. But I had no idea how it was possible and what i thought was as a child i thought that somebody just you know thought about everything anyone could say and just put you know hundreds of thousands of hours into the game um but what i found out later was that you know there's a lot of natural language processing and like statistical tricks that people can play that kind of guide you in a certain direction where it feels like you're doing anything you
你亲手画一张地图，或者现在从互联网下载一张。而我当时还没有准备好买方格纸然后开始，你知道的，手绘地图。所以我从没在那个游戏中走得很远。但是，是的，我认为这些游戏的工作方式总是让我着迷。作为一个很小的孩子，其实，你知道的，我很确定那里没有人类，另一端没有人类在输入这些答案。但我完全不知道这怎么可能。而我小时候的想法是，我觉得有人只是，你知道的，考虑了任何人可能说的每一句话，然后把，你知道的，几十万小时投入到游戏中。但后来我发现，你知道的，有很多自然语言处理和统计技巧，人们可以利用这些技巧在某种程度上引导你朝某个方向前进，让你觉得自己正在做任何你想做的事，
want but you're really not it's kind of just slowly coercing you to do something specific i think for that one the one that uh i guess like the modern equivalent is you ever play the game scribble knots. Oh yeah. The game is great. So, so scribble knots, a game where you're supposed to like get through a level, but you can just type in words and sort of like summon whatever you're
但实际上并不是。它只是慢慢地强迫你去做一些特定的事情。我想对于那款游戏，那个，呃，我猜现代的等价物是你玩过《 Scribblenauts 》(涂鸦上帝/涂鸦冒险家) 吗？哦，是的。这款游戏太棒了。所以，所以《 Scribblenauts 》是一款游戏，你需要通过关卡，但你可以直接输入单词，并召唤出你正在寻找的任何东西。
looking for. And so at first it's sort of confusing. Like you can type in a crazy amount of words, but once you sort of like start pushing the limits out of it, it turns out like many of the words we have mapped to sort of like some foundational object so like jason's saying like natural language processing so how many different kinds of cats can you name you can probably name whatever 20 different kinds of cats but they're all going to collapse down to a generic looking cat that while not expressing what you said gets
所以一开始这有点令人困惑。就像你可以输入数量疯狂的单词，但一旦你开始突破它的极限，结果证明我们映射的许多单词都指向某种基础对象，所以就像杰森说的，像自然语言处理，那么你能说出多少种不同种类的猫？你大概能说出，随便吧，20种不同种类的猫，但它们最终都会坍缩成一只长相平平的猫，虽然没有准确表达你所说的话，但对于一个卡通风格的游戏来说已经足够接近了，你对此也很满意。所以，是的，你也许能说出 10,000 个物体，但在实践中，可能只有，你知道的，程序员需要考虑的几百个，这仍然是一个很大的数字，但要好得多，因为，你知道的，它们中的许多都是常见主题的变体，
you close enough for a cartoonish game where you're satisfied with it. So yeah, you may be able to name 10,000 objects, but in practice, maybe there's only like, you know, a few hundred that the sort of programmer needs to account for, which is still a large number, but much better because, you know, a lot of them are variations on a common theme
或者彼此之间有映射关系，或者只是大小差异，对吧？你可以说出 10 种鲸鱼的名字，但我可以制作一只通用的鲸鱼，然后把它做成稍微不同的大小，你就会满意了。是的，完全正确。我的意思是，还有另外两件事，一个是，文本极其微小，就像，呃，可能整个字典可以装进两张照片里，或者类似的东西。我的意思是，我在试图弄清楚我在规模上是否理解正确，但假设你认为一个字典有多少个字符？这也许是个好问题。假设一本字典大约有 800 页左右，
or have a mapping to each other or just a size difference right you can name 10 kinds of whales but i could make one generic whale and then just make it slightly different sizes and you'll be satisfied yep yeah exactly i mean a couple other things is is one is um text is extremely tiny like uh um like maybe the whole dictionary can fit in two photos or something i mean i'm trying to figure out if i got that right in terms of scale right but let's say how many characters you think a dictionary is maybe that's a good question is let's say a dictionary is like 800 pages or so and so maybe that's like 16 000 characters and so that's like not even a piece
所以也许这就像 16,000 个字符，所以这甚至连一张图片的一部分都算不上，就像一张图片极小的一部分，对吧？嗯，当帕特里克去查的时候，是的，我的意思是，你可以在软盘上装入数量惊人的文本，你知道的，或者 CD 盘，甚至比你读过的还要多的文本。所以，你知道的，尤其是在 80 年代和 90 年代，感觉这些世界绝对是巨大的，因为它们全都是文本。所以其中许多事情运作的方式是，有一个叫做 WordNet 的开源东西。WordNet 真的非常迷人。它是所有单词的树状结构，地球上所有的名词，对吧？所以 WordNet 中一切的根源就是实体 (entity)，字面意思上一切都是实体。然后我认为在那个点上，下一层级要么是抽象 (abstraction)，要么是人工制品 (artifact)，我想。
of an image like a tiny piece of an image right um so while patrick looks it up yeah i mean you can fit an insane amount of text on a floppy disk you know or a cd right even way more text you'd ever read and so you know especially you know in the 80s and the 90s it just felt like these worlds were absolutely enormous because they were all in text and so the the way a lot of these things worked is there is a open source thing called wordNet. WordNet is really fascinating. It's a tree of all the words, all the nouns on the planet, right? So the root of everything in WordNet is entity, like literally everything is an entity. And then I think at that point, it's either an abstraction or an artifact, I think, is the next level.
但基本上，你可以放入任何你想要的词，独角兽、老虎、沙发或任何东西。它都会是一个节点。如果它是一个名词，它就会是这棵树中的一个节点。然后还有 VerbNet，它或多或少是动词的同类东西。所以，正如帕特里克在谈到《 Scribblenauts 》时所说的那样，你知道的，你可能会在你的文本冒险描述中说类似的话，你知道的，桌子上有一个鲸鱼的雕像。而编写它的程序员会查看 WordNet，他们会说，好的，鲸鱼是这种水生动物，这是一种鱼，这是一种动物，这是一种实体或别的什么。他们可能会说，好吧，我只选“动物”。所以如果这个人说“捡起动物”或“捡起鲸鱼”，甚至“捡起狮子”，它都会捡起鲸鱼的雕像，因为他们把它做得那么通用，
But basically, like you can put in any word you want, narwhal or tiger or couch or anything. And it will be a node. If it's a noun, it will be a node in this tree. And then there's verb net, which is more or less the same thing for verbs. And so, you know, as Patrick was saying with Scribblenauts, you know, you might in your description in your text adventure, you might say something like, you know, there's a statue of a whale on the table. And the programmer who programs it, they'll look at word net and they'll say, OK, a whale is this type of like aquatic animal, which is a fish, which is an animal, which is an entity or whatever. And they might say, okay, I'm just going to pick animal. So if the person says, pick up the animal or pick up the whale, or even pick up the lion, it'll pick up the statue of the whale because they made it that generic,
对吧？所以你可能会，游戏可能会告诉你有一个独角兽雕像，但如果你说“捡起鱼”，它还是会把它捡起来。这种戏法就是让事情感觉如此开放和神奇的原因。就像你可以说，向北走，或步行向北，或移动向北，或向北旅行。不需要做太多工作，程序员就可以把所有这些概念坍缩成同一个概念。牛津英语词典有 3.5 亿个字符，所以那是，呃，就像 3.5 兆字节 (MB)，对吧？
right? And so you might, the game might tell you there's a statue of a narwhal, but if you say pick up the fish, it'll still pick it up. And so that trickery there is what makes things feel so open-ended and magical. Like you can say, go north or walk north or move north or travel north. And without a lot of work, the programmer can make all of those kind of collapse the same concept so the oxford english dictionary is 350 million characters so that's uh it's like 350 megabytes right yeah so what is that in terms like mega is a megapixel the same as a mega i don't really know how to relate that oh dude we're gonna get trouble but it's 350 megabytes it's basically like 100
所以这在概念上是什么，兆像素和兆字节是一样的吗？我真的不知道该怎么关联那个。哦，天哪，我们要惹麻烦了，但它是 3.5 兆字节，基本上就像 100 张照片。但我们正在谈论的 WordNet 只有 16 兆字节。是的，因为你，因为你不需要保留——牛津英语词典有多少内容是冗余的呢，对吧？如果你要压缩它的话——所以这些词并没有在 WordNet 中定义，它们只是在彼此的关系中被定义，它们只是通过关系连接在一起的，
photos but word net which we're talking about is only 16 megabytes yeah so because you because you don't need to keep like how much of the oxford english dictionary is redundant though right like if you were to compress it so like these words aren't defined in word net they're only defined in the relationship to each other they're just relationally connected yeah so it could actually be even more compact and that says i mean i don't know it's looked like it started in the 80s and it's not been updated in a few years about 10 10 years. But yeah, so it's 16 megabytes. So even if you took a small skim off of just some fraction of them, you could easily fit this in a sort of game a long time ago. Yeah, exactly.
所以它实际上可能更加紧凑，我的意思是，我不知道，看起来它始于 80 年代，并且已经有几年没有更新了，大约 10 年，10 年了。但是，是的，所以它是 16 兆字节。所以即使你只从中截取一小部分，你也可以轻而易举地把它塞进很久以前的某种游戏中。是的，完全正确。
And you could also, in post-processing, you could eliminate all the words that didn't actually show up in your game or something. Oh, that's true. Yeah. But yeah, so it's you know, it's a combination of the fact that text is so cheap and, you know, some of these foundational technologies being around even in the eighties that, that made text adventures just really magical. I mean, I remember thinking that I could just say anything and, and just mapped it to something that was at least directionally, you know, kind of in line with what i with what i wanted these characters to reply with and so i remember just really falling
而且你还可以在后处理中消除那些实际上没有在你的游戏中出现的单词或者别的什么。哦，真的吗？是的。但是，是的，所以你知道的，这是因为文本非常便宜，而且，你知道的，其中一些基础技术甚至在 80 年代就已经存在，这使得文本冒险游戏真正变得神奇。我的意思是，我还记得当时认为我可以畅所欲言，并且，只需将它映射到至少在方向上，你知道的，符合我想要的这些角色回复的内容上。所以我还记得自己真的爱上了这些游戏，并玩了无数的游戏。
in love with these with these games and playing a ton of them um yeah i mean there was actually a lot of adult content not like uh triple x content or anything like all these games have like smoking and drinking or you would get shot or whatever but uh fortunately my parents would just let me buy just about anything so so uh so yeah it was uh it was uh pretty wild but it was it was a ton of fun and uh i highly recommend going back if you were to go back and play sex adventures now definitely check out the ifdb interactive fiction database um they have kind of like a best games of all time you know most of these games you can play on the internet for free now i guess if i had to pick one i would suggest folks play photopia which is uh it's an awesome
嗯，我的意思是，里面实际上有很多成人内容，不是那种三级片内容或者别的什么，而是所有这些游戏都有吸烟和喝酒，或者你会中枪之类的，但幸运的是，我的父母只会让我买几乎任何东西，所以，所以，是的，这，这，相当疯狂，但真的超级好玩，而且我强烈建议回过头去——如果你现在要回去玩文本冒险游戏，一定要去看看 IFDB（互动小说数据库），那里有类似于史上最佳游戏的东西，你知道的，现在你基本上可以在互联网上免费玩大多数这类游戏。我想如果我必须选一个，我会建议大家玩《Photopia》，它是一个很棒的游戏，它非常线性，这对新手来说很好，对吧？哦，对我来说，是的，走吧，对，对，糟糕，任何，实际上我认为在描述的开头，在加粗的描述顶部，它直接准确地告诉你应该做什么，你知道的，在一个高层次上，比如离开这个岛，或者探索这艘船之类的。
game it's very linear which is good for beginners right oh for me yeah let's go yeah for bad yeah any actually i think in the beginning of the description like at the top of the description in bold it just tells you exactly what you're supposed to be doing you know at a high level like get off the island or like explore the ship or something um and so you know it's very linear um it's linear as from a gameplay perspective, but you're actually moving around in time. So the story is very interesting. It's an extremely touching story.
所以，你知道的，它是非常线性的，从游戏玩法的角度来看它是线性的，但你实际上是在时间中四处移动。所以这个故事非常有趣。这是一个极其感人的故事。
Like it's very, it has an extremely tragic ending that will bring you to tears. It's very heart-wrenching story. You could beat the whole thing in like three hours, maybe, maybe even less so there's uh yeah it's not gonna be a huge time sink they have it on the phone and everything it's it's like the most popular interactive fiction game so it probably has dedicated apps and everything all right i'm gonna make it homework to uh to go try this one out so i can try out photopia it is deep and so actually another shameless plug
就像它有一个极其悲惨的结局，会让你落泪。这是一个非常揪心的故事。你可以在大概三个小时内通关整个游戏，也许，甚至更快。所以，是的，它不会消耗你大量的时间。他们在手机和其他平台上都有这款游戏，它是最受欢迎的互动小说游戏，所以它可能拥有专门的应用程序和一切。好的，我要把它当成家庭作业，去尝试一下这个，这样我就可以体验《Photopia》了。它很深奥，所以实际上，另一个厚颜无耻的广告，在我们做厚颜无耻的广告的同时，我创建了一个网站 visual-if.com，我在那里拿了游戏《Photopia》，并用一个非常非常非常老版本的 DALL-E 运行了它。这是在——当时我是极少数能够使用 DALL-E 的人之一，远在他们发布它之前，纯粹通过我的人脉关系，我渲染了大量的图像内容。但我实际上需要回去用最新的 DALL-E 重新制作这一切，因为那样会好上一百万倍，
while we're doing shameless plugs i created a website visual-if.com where i took the game photopia and i ran it against a really old old old version of dolly this is before back when like i was one of very few people who could use dolly way before they announced it just through connections i had i i rendered a ton of of content but i'm actually i need to go back and redo it all with the latest dolly because it would be a million times better um but you can go there and while you're playing the game it's rendering photos of the game which is uh i think something that we should be uh trying to do with all of these games so we talked about like reducing the words or using ontologies to kind of like map and understand what you're attempting to do but i think the other thing that uh from my reading about a lot of these is sure
但你可以去那里，当你玩游戏时，它会实时渲染游戏的图片，我认为这应该是我们应该在所有这些游戏上尝试去做的事情。所以我们讨论了减少词汇量，或者使用本体论来映射和理解你试图做什么，但我认为另一件从我阅读许多这类游戏中学到的事情是，确切地说，杰森刚才谈到了在网上查找迷宫地图并把它画出来，但我的意思是，自从我甚至不知道多久以前开始，迷宫生成就已经成为我称之为过程生成 (procedural generation) 的一种形式，许多这类游戏都可以使用它。所以现在如果你去玩这个游戏，你有了关于规则的设定——你知道的，我需要一个入口，一个出口，我希望这些类型的房间被完成，然后你可以编写一个程序来动态生成它们。然后每次你玩的时候，
you jason was talking about like looking up online with the mazes uh and sort of drawing it out but i mean since i don't even know how long like maze generation has been a form of what i'll call procedural generation that a lot of these games could use so now if you go to play the game and you have rules for you know i need one need one way in, one way out, I want these kinds of rooms to be done, then you can write a procedure for generating these on the fly. And then every time you play,
结果都会略有不同。我认为过程生成就像我们之前提到的《我的世界》和其他游戏一样，在今天继续非常非常受欢迎。我们可能会有一整期节目来讨论各种生成过程的方法。但对我来说很有趣的想法是，当我想到编写一个迷宫generator时，
it's going to end up being a little bit different. And I think procedural generation is something like we already referenced sort of Minecraft and others that continues to be very, very popular today. And we'll probably have a whole show to talk about various ways of doing procedural generation. But it's interesting to me to think like I, when I think about writing a maze generator,
我感觉人们在学习计算机科学时很早就接触到了这一点，你总是会从可视化的角度去思考它，但在这里你可以制造一个没有可视画面呈现的迷宫。相反，你实际上是通过纯文本的方式试图穿过这个迷宫。我想如果你想用难度设置来任意虐人的话，你可以制作一个非常复杂的迷宫，玩家试图通过文字描述来通过它。对。而且有了文本，它甚至不必是欧几里得空间的。你可以拥有非欧几里得空间。
which I feel like people get introduced to pretty early when they do computer science, you always think about it in the sort of visual representation, but here you could make a maze with no visual representation. And instead, you're literally text-based sort of attempting to move through the maze. I guess if you wanted to be arbitrarily brutal with a difficulty setting, you could make a very complicated maze that the person is attempting to get through via description. Right. And with text, it doesn't even have to be Euclidean. Like you could have non-Euclidean spaces.
相信我，我见过一些痛苦的互动小说游戏，其中……这东西真的存在吗？就像《传送门》(Portal) 那样，你知道的，折叠空间？没有。哦，没有。是的。我的意思是，有些这样的游戏甚至不是，这在某种程度上只是一种糟糕的设计。
Trust me, I've seen some painful interactive fiction games where... Is that a thing? Like portal, like, you know, folded spaces? No. Oh, no. Yeah. I mean, like there's some of these games and it's not even, it's kind of just bad design.
例如，你可能会向东走，然后向上走，然后向下走。你会觉得如果你向西走，你就会回到你开始的地方。但游戏向下的方式实际上也把你带向了西边。所以这些游戏里充斥着各种奇怪的非欧几里得空间。
Like for example, you might go east and then go up and then go down. And you kind of think that if you went west, you'd be back where you started. But just the way the game was going down actually also moved you west. So there's just all these like weird non-Euclidean things to a lot of these games.
是的，单向门以及各种东西。所以情况可能会变得相当棘手。这就是游戏测试的用武之地……你无法避开游戏测试，尤其是对基于文本的游戏而言。但是，是的，我认为过程生成……实际上，《失忆症》就是一个很好的例子，最终你会找到一种方法离开你的酒店而不被枪杀。你刚刚已经告诉我们了，你已经剧透了。是的，是的，剧透了，你在前五分钟不会被枪杀，但你需要花大约一个小时才能弄清楚这一点——你必须，呃，
Yeah, one-way doors and everything. So it can get pretty gnarly. And that's where playtesting... You can't get away from playtesting, especially with text-based games. But yeah, I think the procedural... Actually, Amnesia is a good example where eventually you will find a way to leave your hotel without getting shot you already told us you already spoiled it yeah yeah spoiler you won't get shot in the first five minutes but it takes you like for an hour to figure it out like you have to uh there's there's
游戏中有这样一个点，呃，是的，你走出去，然后你中枪了，然后就变成了“好吧，我弄清楚了如何不被枪杀，哦，但我忘了穿衣服，他们直到为时已晚才告诉我，所以现在我因为赤身裸体而被捕了，然后游戏就结束了”。当然，就游戏设计而言，这是一团糟。但如果你能安然无恙地走到曼哈顿的街头，你将拥有字面意义上整个曼哈顿，而且所有最受欢迎的建筑都在正确的街道上，你可以去任何一条街道，街道的连接方式和曼哈顿一模一样。他们把整座城市都塞进了一张软盘里，这简直太了不起了。正如你所说，我认为几乎所有的描述
one point in the game where where yeah you walk out you get shot and it's like okay i figured out how to not get shot oh but i forgot to put clothes on and they didn't tell me until it's too late and so now i get arrested for being naked and then the game's over of course it was uh you know a mess as far as game design is concerned but if you could make it out onto the streets and you're in Manhattan, if you could make it out onto the streets of Manhattan safely, you literally had literally all of Manhattan and like all the most popular buildings were on the right street and you could go to any street and the streets connected the same way they do in Manhattan. And they'd put the entire city there on a floppy disk, which was just absolutely remarkable. And as you said, I think it was almost all the descriptions
都是临时拼凑在一起的。比如每一个十字路口并没有固定的描述，它完全是由按需组合在一起的一堆事实构成的。我觉得互动小说和——虽然我从未玩过，但桌上角色扮演游戏 (TRPG) 之间总是有一种联系，在那种游戏中，你知道的，地下城主 (DM) 对地下城有一个描述，你在其中穿行，这很酷。但一直让我着迷的是，其中一些游戏变成了一种合作式的故事讲述。就像我们在合作决定
were kind of like pieced together on the fly. Like there wasn't a fixed description of every intersection. It was all just composed of a bunch of facts that they joined together on demand. I feel like there's always a relationship between interactive fiction and then I've never done them, but tabletop RPGs where like,
什么，你就像刚才说的几乎可以做任何你想做的事——我想买张机票去夏威夷度一个星期的假。好的，那会对世界产生什么影响呢？而不是预先设定好的你必须按我的方式来做，甚至不一定有一个清晰的目的地。我从来没有能够玩过那样的一款游戏，但我一直认为，如果能进入这种讲故事的模式会非常酷，这不是主角与反派的关系。这只是有点像，
you know, the dungeon master sort of has a description of the dungeon and you're moving through it, which is cool. But the thing that has always fascinated me is some of them, it becomes like a cooperative storytelling. Like we are collaboratively deciding
我选择做某件事，然后你顺着这件事进行即兴创作。所以这是一种非常即兴的风格。我觉得互动小说试图在某种程度上实现这一点。随着我们一直在谈论的一些工具，比如过程生成和人工智能，感觉你最终可以实现这一点，游戏可以随心所欲，你只玩一款游戏，而游戏就是，你知道的，任何你想要的东西，无论你玩的是什么游戏风格。
what and you get like you're kind of saying almost do anything you want like i want to get an airplane and go to hawaii and just take a vacation for a week okay well what does that do to the world right and rather than a pre-can you got to do it my way it's there's not even necessarily a clear destination i've never been able to kind of like play a game like that, but I always thought it would be really cool to kind of like get into this storytelling mode where it's not a protagonist antagonist relationship. It's just sort of like,
你的意思是，你可以几乎随心所欲，比如我想坐飞机去夏威夷度个为期一周的假，好吧，那这会对世界产生什么影响呢？而且它不是那种预先设定好“你必须按我的方式来”的模式，甚至不一定有一个清晰的目的我从来没有真正玩过那种游戏，但我一直觉得，如果能进入这种讲故事的模式，会非常酷——它不是主角与反派的关系，而更像是，
I'm choosing to do something and then you're riffing off of the thing. And so it's a very improv style. And I feel like interactive fiction attempts to kind of get a part of the way there. And with some of these tools, we've been talking about like procedural generation and ai it feels like you could ultimately get to this where like the game could just be whatever you want you just one game and the game is just you know whatever you want it to be whatever play style you're playing and
我选择去做某件事，然后你顺着这件事即兴发挥。所以这是一种非常即兴的风格。我觉得交互式小说试图达到这种效果的一部分。随着我们一直在讨论的其中一些工具，比如程序生成和人工智能，感觉你最终可以实现这一点，游戏可以随心所欲——你只有一款游戏，而这款游戏就是你想要的任何内容，无论你采用什么游戏风格，它都能满足你
maybe there's some still game elements to make it a game but it even maybe loses that distinction a bit because you're just fishing off the coast of you know bermuda for reasons and you have a whole career as a fisherman now and it becomes a fishing simulator and you know someone else is playing something completely different yeah you know i also never played tabletop but i've heard just fantastic stories from friends who have played it the one that comes to mind someone said that they were they were trapped in like a jungle and they were surrounded by lions or monsters or something and someone had figured out that he could cast his icicle spell on a tree and instead of trying to like injure someone with the icicle spell which is what you know the game is designed around instead they just cast it on a tree hit the tree with an icicle and then put
也许仍然有一些游戏元素让它成为一款游戏，但它甚至可能有点失去了这种区别，因为你只是在百慕大海岸钓鱼，出于某些原因，你现在有了一整套渔夫的职业，它变成了一个钓鱼模拟器，你知道另一个人在玩完全不同的东西，是的，你知道我从来没玩过桌游，但我听玩过的朋友讲过非常棒的故事，我能想到的一个是，有人说他们被困在一个丛林里，周围都是狮子、怪物之类的东西，有人想出他可以在树上施放冰锥术，而不是像游戏设计那样试图用冰锥伤害某人，相反，他们只是把它施放在树上，用冰锥击中树，然后放
a bucket under the icicle so that they all could drink so that they could survive in the wilderness it's like that kind of like you know just human ingenuity it's it's uh i think that's why it requires a human dungeon master but the maybe again with all this generative ai maybe there's something that people could do there like that programmers could do there i feel like we're getting into some some description of a metaverse i feel like there's gonna there's a there's a there's a side rabbit trail here but uh i think we'll just leave that one aside for now yeah it's so true yeah that's uh it's, but I think we'll just leave that one aside for now. Yeah, it's so true. Yeah, that's, it's wild.
把桶放在冰锥下面，这样他们就可以喝水，以便在荒野中生存，这就像那种人类的聪明才智，我觉得这就是为什么它需要一个人类地下城主，但也许有了所有这些生成式人工智能，也许人们可以在那里做一些程序员可以在那里做的事情，我觉得我们正在进入元宇宙的一些描述，我觉得这里有一个支线兔子洞，但是我觉得我们现在先把那个搁置一边，是的，太对了，是的，那是，但我想我们现在先把那个搁置一边，是的，太对了，是的，那是，太疯狂了。
But I think, you know, definitely, you know, take some time to check out IFTB and check out Photopia. If you want to make an interactive fiction, there's a bunch of tools to help you do it. You know, in the case of the Fortuna, the thing that I talked about in the tool of the show, I wanted to integrate ChatGPT. And so I had to basically write the parser by hand. That took a lot of time. I mean, I have a background in AI and all of that. So it was
但我认为，你知道，绝对地，花点时间看看 IFTB 和 Photopia。如果你想创作互动小说，有很多工具可以帮助你。你知道，以 Fortuna 为例，我在节目工具里谈到的那个，我想整合 ChatGPT。所以我基本上不得不手写解析器。这花了很多时间。我的意思是，我有 AI 背景之类的。所以
not too bad, but I wouldn't really recommend that to folks. There are a bunch of amazing tools out there for generating text-based games. And one of the most common is called Inform. So Inform was, I believe it was the tool that one of these companies that made a ton of these games used Inform. And then eventually Inform became a tool that you could buy, and then it became a tool that you could buy and then it became a tool that you could use for free and then now i think it's even open source but inform is really interesting you actually create the game the source code of your game is english so your game source code is like, there is a room. Here's the description of the room.
不太糟糕，但我真的不推荐给其他人。市面上有许多用于生成文字游戏的精彩工具。最常见的一种叫做 Inform。所以 Inform 曾经是，我相信制造大量这类游戏的其中一家公司使用的工具就是 Inform。然后 Inform 最终变成了一个你可以购买的工具，然后它变成了一个你可以购买的工具，然后它变成了一个你可以免费使用的工具，现在我想它甚至开源了，但 Inform 真的很有趣，你实际创建游戏，你的游戏的源代码是英文的，所以你的游戏源代码就像是，这里有一个房间。这里是房间的描述。
There's a torch in the room. You can pick up the torch. There's a chest in the room. The chest is openable. The chest has its own inventory. Like you literally say literally those words. And then that's the source code to the game. And so that by itself, I mean, maybe that deserves a whole show on like, it's like prose source code.
房间里有一把火炬。你可以捡起火炬。房间里有一个箱子。箱子是可以打开的。箱子有它自己的物品栏。就像你字面意思上说出这些话一样。然后这就是游戏的源代码。所以仅凭这一点，我的意思是，也许这值得做一整期节目，比如，它就像是散文源代码。
But that's fascinating. You know, it's worth trying to make a game and inform just because of the whole experience there. Wow, this is crazy. I'm looking at it now. And so they're giving an example of how you would describe a room. So I'm just going to read this one from their page. East of the garden is the gazebo above is the treehouse a billiards table is in the gazebo on it is a trophy cup
但那太迷人了。你知道，值得尝试用 Inform 做一款游戏，仅仅为了那整个体验。哇，这太疯狂了。我现在正在看。所以他们给出了一个如何描述房间的例子。所以我打算直接读他们页面上的这一段。花园的东边是凉亭，上方是树屋，凉亭里有一张台球桌，上面有一个奖杯
a starting pistol is in the cup in the treehouse is a container called a cardboard box that's crazy that like yeah it's almost like you're writing how you would play an interactive fiction game to make it interactive fiction game. Yeah, exactly. Yeah, it's totally mind blowing. It's the kind of thing where, you know, it is kind of restrictive. Like, it wasn't clear to me how to, like, integrate that with ChadGBT. You know, it's not like programming. But it's really interesting. It's a great way for people to get started
奖杯里有一把发令枪，树屋里有一个叫纸板箱的容器，太疯狂了，就像你几乎是在写你将如何玩互动小说游戏来制作互动小说游戏。是的，完全正确。是的，这完全大开眼界。这是那种，你知道，确实有点限制性的东西。比如，我不清楚如何将它与 ChatGPT 整合。你知道，这不像编程。但这真的很有趣，这是人们开始的绝佳方式
just building anything on the computer. If you're looking for something that's more traditional, there's also TADS, Text Adventure Development System. That's more of like a traditional programming language where you kind of assign properties to things. And there's probably like JSON or YAML. There's some file that describes the different objects and everything. But, yeah, there's there's a lot of really good content.
在电脑上构建任何东西。如果你在寻找更传统的东西，还有 TADS，即文字冒险开发系统。这更像是一种传统的编程语言，你将属性分配给事物。可能还有 JSON 或 YAML。有一些文件描述了不同的对象和所有东西。但是，是的，有很多非常好的内容。
You know, and then as far as designing, designing a good interactive fiction game, I want to recommend Emily Short's blog. She has a fantastic blog on how to design it, how to keep people motivated. You know, what's a good way to start a game like that. So like amnesia is an example of a bad way to start a game because it's like, open the door, you died,
你知道，至于设计，设计一款优秀的互动小说游戏，我想推荐艾米丽·肖特（Emily Short）的博客。她有一个非常棒的博客，关于如何设计它，如何保持人们的动力。你知道，开始这样一款游戏的好方法是什么。所以像《失忆症》就是一个糟糕的开局例子，因为就像是，打开门，你死了，
you know? So it's, you need to kind of start with something that's very guided where people, you know, you kind of give all the right hints for someone to do x and they do x and you pat them on the head and say good job just to make sure people could do the basic concepts and then start moving into trying to assemble intuition so that you if you're following things right and if you're observant, you could go through the whole game without dying.
你知道吗？所以你需要从一些非常引导性的东西开始，人们，你知道，你给出一个做某事的正确提示，他们做了，你拍拍他们的头说干得好，只是为了确保人们能做基本的概念，然后开始尝试建立直觉，这样如果你遵循正确的事情并且善于观察，你就可以通关整个游戏而不会死。
And when you die, you find out, okay, I actually should have seen that coming. And so she and other game designers are really good at explaining how to do that properly. So yeah, a bunch of great resources. I highly recommend people give it a shot. It's really fun. And I think this is an area that's ripe for generative AI. I mean, I took a crack at it with my thing, but I think in general, having this sort of generative AI that can sort of weave itself into the story
当你死的时候，你会发现，好吧，我其实应该预料到这一点的。所以她和其他游戏设计师非常擅长解释如何正确做到这一点。所以，是的，有很多伟大的资源。我强烈建议大家尝试一下。真的很有趣。而且我认为这是一个非常适合生成式人工智能的领域。我的意思是，我用我的东西尝试过，但我总觉得，拥有这种能够将自己编织进故事中的生成式人工智能
is something that is going to profoundly change these text-based games. I think it might even bring the bring a second life to them but if not at least it's going to be extremely transformative to them because you know for example you might say oh the bricks are really mossy when you're writing the description of some cave and you're just you know filling in content you don't really want the player to care a lot about the bricks you're just you know filling in content you don't really want the player to care a lot about the bricks you're just you know continuing to build the atmosphere world building yeah world building that's right but your player doesn't have your brain right and so they might think
将深刻改变这些文字游戏。我认为它甚至可能给它们带来第二生命，但如果不是，至少会对它们产生极大的变革，因为你知道，例如，当你写某个洞穴的描述时，你可能会说哦，砖块真的很苔藓，你只是在填充内容，你其实并不希望玩家太在意砖块，你只是在填充内容，你其实并不希望玩家太在意砖块，你只是在继续构建氛围，世界构建，是的，世界构建，没错，但是你的玩家没有你的大脑，对吧，所以他们可能会想
oh there's something to that and they might want to look at the bricks and so you know and if you say something like oh the bricks aren't here or like there's nothing interesting about that, like a generic answer, then it's kind of gets a little frustrating. And so here you have the potential to like have an AI describe anything. And it's really going to change this field in a huge, huge way. Even, you know, adjacent things like we talked about bethesda games like imagine skyrim but you could just say anything you want to the npcs and they will answer you know in an atmospheric way i think there's just something incredibly powerful there well i learned a lot today about interactive fiction as a genre that i've always heard about
哦，这其中有什么门道，他们可能会想看看砖块，所以你知道，如果你说类似哦，砖块不在这里，或者类似那里没有什么有趣的东西，就像一个通用的回答，那么就会变得有点令人沮丧。所以在这里你有潜力让 AI 描述任何东西。这真的会以巨大无比的方式改变这个领域。甚至，你知道，诸如我们讨论过的贝塞斯达游戏之类相邻的东西，就像想象一下《天际》，但你可以对 NPC 说任何你想说的话，他们会以一种有氛围的方式回应，我认为那里有某种不可思议的强大力量，今天我学到了很多关于互动小说作为一种我一直听说但从未做过的流派的知识
but never done so so i've got my homework to go play. I've got to open up in a tab already. So apparently I'm going to cry at the end. So I'm not sure I'm ready for that, but here we're going to go. Yeah, I mean, I don't consider myself a particularly sentimental person, but when it comes to movies or games or something where there's something tragic, I guess I'm a sucker for being sad at tragic things or something. I don't know exactly how to describe that. But even if they start playing the song, if a main character is going to get injured or die or something, you just get that song that starts playing.
但从来没做过，所以我有家庭作业要去玩。我已经在一个标签页里打开了它。所以显然我最后会哭。所以我不确定我是否准备好了，但我们要开始了。是的，我的意思是，我不认为自己是一个特别多愁善感的人，但当涉及到电影或游戏或有悲剧发生的事情时，我想我就是忍不住为悲剧事情感到难过之类的人。我不知道该怎么确切描述。但即使他们开始播放那首歌，如果一个主要角色要受伤或死去什么的，你就会听到那首歌开始播放。
The most nearest example is when Luke Skywalker, you know, old Luke Skywalker. Well, I might spoil something important. Anyways, basically, I'll spoil it. Old Luke Skywalker sacrifices his life in one of the Star Wars movies. And I started tearing up like I'm just a sucker for that stuff, I guess. So you might not cry in Photopia. That's where I'm going with this I have a very low barrier to entry for for crying happy stuff cool well hey definitely you know uh folks out there
最近的例子是当卢克·天行者，你知道，老卢克·天行者。好吧，我可能会剧透一些重要的东西。无论如何，基本上，我会剧透的。老卢克·天行者在其中一部星球大战电影中牺牲了自己的生命。然后我开始流泪，我大概就是忍不住那种东西。所以你在《Photopia》里可能不会哭。这就是我的意思，我对哭泣、快乐的事物的门槛很低，酷，好吧，嘿，绝对地，各位朋友
check out interactive fiction it's a ton of fun it's a great way to get started coding there's a ton of free games that are super high quality, very accessible. You can play on your phone, you can play on anything. It's just text. We will catch everyone next time. Thanks again for supporting the show. Thanks, Patrick, for putting up with me. This is my episode that I really wanted to get out there. So thanks for indulging me in an interactive fiction episode. And we'll catch y'all later music by eric barn dollar programming throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Sharealike 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide an attribution to Patrick and I and sharealike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
去看看互动小说吧，它非常有趣，是开始编程的好方法，有大量的免费游戏，质量超级高，非常容易接触。你可以在手机上玩，你可以在任何设备上玩。它只是文字。我们下次节目再见。再次感谢大家支持本节目。谢谢帕特里克忍受我。这是我真正想要发布的一集。所以谢谢你让我任性地做了一期互动小说节目。我们回头见，eric barn dollar 的音乐，Programming Throwdown 在知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 许可下分发。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，重新混音、改编作品，但你必须对我和帕特里克进行署名，并以相同方式共享。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可留下评论。